Bör büce kemik kadro öğrencim YouTube'un
en büyük coğrafi kanalına hepiniz hoş
geldiniz. 39 gün dt coğrafya ayrıntılı
kampımızın bugün geldik gençler 36.
gününe. Bugün en önemli konulardan bir
tanesini işliyoruz. Afetleri
öğreneceğiz. Biraz uzun bir video olacak
çünkü kapsamlı bir konu. Bu konu çok
değerli bir konudur. Bölgeler konusundan
sonra en değerli konu budur. Bölgeler
kısadır. Her sene bir soru gelir. Niye
en önemlisi o diyorum? Çünkü kısa
anlaması da kolay. Her sene bir soru
geliyor bölgelerden. Bu afetler konusu
biraz uzun ayrıntılıdır ama her sene
sekmeden hem MS'de hem de TYT'de soru
gelmiştir. O yüzden dikkatli
dinliyorsunuz. Kampızda bu video gelene
kadar bir iki günlük bir aksama oldu.
Çünkü biliyorsunuz takip etmişsinizdir
Instagram'dan ya da YouTube'un shorts
kısa video kısmından. Zeduava
öğretmenleri ile beraber Ankara'daydık.
Zeduava'nın açılışını yaptık. Bir iki
günlük bir aksama oldu. Kusura bakmayın.
Aslında ben stok yaparak gitmiştim ama
bu kadar orada kalacağımı tahmin
etmemiştim. O yüzden bir iki günlük
aksam oldu. Hiç kusura bakmayın. Diğer
videolarda hızlıca gelecek kampı
bitireceğiz diyorum. Ve ne diyorum?
Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha
asla unutma. Zedoa ile eğitim her yerde.
Şimdi geldik bakın şurada 36 günde
afetler konusundayız. Afetlerin üstünü
çizin. Burada dikkat edin. 76 77
ayrı test çözeceğiz. Neden? Çünkü bu
konu en önemli konulardan bir tanesi.
Özellikle bu konuyla alakalı soru çözümü
çok değerli. soru çözümünü izlemeden
kesinlikle bu konuyu bitirdim deme.
Çünkü farklı farklı sorular haritalar
üzerinde sorulabiliyor. Senin de bunları
görmen, nasıl çözüldüğünü iyice analiz
etmen lazım. O yüzden buraya çok fazla
soru koydum gençler. Aslında bu
kampımızın son günü. Ne demek? Bakın
kampımızda şurada üç tane konu var.
Dünyanın şekli ve hareketleri, coğrafi
konum, harita bilgisi. Normalde bu
kitabımızın en başındaydı. Kampların
genelde en başında olan konular bunlar.
Ama biz ne yaptık? Siz çaresizlik
yaşamayın diye. O başta olan konuları en
sona koyduk. Şu ana kadar dikkat et bak.
Kampı bitirdin aslında sen. Afetleri
bitirdiğinde coğrafyayı bitirdim
diyebilirsin kendine. Hiç merak etme. Ne
yaptın? Hiçbir çaresizlik yaşadın mı bu
kamp biterken? Yaşamadın. Aa coğrafyayı
anlamıyorum ben diye bir duygu geldi mi
sana? Gelmedi. Ne yaptın? En başta
hevesli bir şekilde başladın. Ben bu
konuları sona aldığım için düzenli bir
şekilde gittin. Gittin gittin. Bak kampı
bitirebildin. Kampı bitirmek de önemli
olan zaten. Çünkü herkes başlıyor
kamplara. Ama arada bunlar olsaydı
bitiremeyecektin. Bunları açmak çok zor.
Bunlar bir de çok uzun konular ve
anlaması da zor konular olunca seni pes
ettiriyor. Aldık sırayla en sona koyduk.
Ben inanıyorum bu zamana kadar pes
etmemişsindir. Afetleri de öğrendikten
sonra şunu söyle kendine. Ben coğrafyayı
bitirdim. Tamam mı? Ben yine bu konuları
sana anlatacağım. Bu videodan sonra
gelecek bunların videosu. Ama şunu
unutma afetler de bitince aslında senin
kampın bitti. Hiç kendine dert etme.
Tamam mı? Bu afetler konusundan sonra
bunları sana attığımda böyle çok
ayrıntılı öğrenmeye çalışma ama hiç
izlemeden de geçme tamam. Bu üç videoyu
da izleyeceksin. Neyse şimdi gelelim
afetler konusuna. Şimdi gençler afetin
tanımına bakalım. Bak canlı ve cansız
çevreye zarar veren insanların normal
yaşantısını durduran ya da kesintiye
uğratan can ve mal kaybına neden olan
olaylara verilen isimdir. Bak demek ki
can mal kaybına neden oluyor. İnsanların
normal yaşantısını kesintiye uğratacak.
Canlı cansız çevreye zarar verecek.
Bunlar afetler. Burada şu ayrımı unutma.
Bak normalde biz afetler kısmını
anlatırken hep doğal afetler diye
diyorduk buna. Geçmişte de aslında
hataya düşüyordu. Buna doğal afetler
demek mantıklı değil. Çünkü konumuzda da
bak dikkat et yukarı afetler konusu.
Afetleri biz doğal afet ve beşeri afet
olarak ayırıyoruz. Doğada buradaki fark
ne? Ağırlıklı olarak ya da tamamen doğal
koşullardan dolayı oluştuğunda buna
doğal afet diyoruz. Tabii ki burada bak
ne diyor? Ağırlıklı olarak doğadan
oluşacak insan etkisi olabilir az da
olsa ama ağırlıklı olarak doğada
oluşuyorsa doğadan dolayı o zaman doğal
afet. Bir de ne var? Beşeri afetler. Bak
nükleer ve biyolojik kazalar, patlamalar
gibi. Burada asıl olay ne? İnsan
faaliyetleri sonucunda ortaya çıkıyorsa
nükleer kazalar. İnsan yapıyor nükleeri.
Doğayla alakalı değil. O zaman beşeri
afet olmuş oluyor. Tamam. Burada önemli
olan şunun altını çizmeni istiyorum
senden. Gençler şunu unutmayın.
Sorularda da böyle çıkar karşımıza.
ülkeler verir. Bu ülkelerden hangisi
daha az etkilenir, hangisi fazla
etkilenir gibi. Gelişmiş ülkeler doğal
afetlerden çok fazla etkilenmez. Çünkü
gelişmiş ülkeler önlem almıştır. O doğal
afet evet ülkesinde fazla yaşanıyordur
ama can ve mal kaybına neden olmasına o
kadar fazla izin vermez. Bunu nasıl
yapabilirsiniz? Örnek olarak 9
büyüklüğünde bir deprem Japonya'da
yaşandığında kimse ölmezken 7
büyüklüğünde bir deprem bizim ülkemizde
yaşandığında binlerce insan hayatını
kaybedebiliyor. Bunun nedeni ne? Bu
gelişmişlikle alakalı. Çünkü gelişmemiş
ülkeler önlem almıyorlar. Gelişmiş
ülkelerse önlem aldıkları için can ve
mal kayıpları gelişmiş ülkelerde daha
azdır. Bunu unutmayın. Şimdi bakın
afetler tablomuz bu. Ben eee son
zamanlarda aslında Türkiye haritası ve
Türkiye üzerinden soruyorlar afetleri
ama artık bunu normal ve genel sormaları
gerektiğini düşünüyorum. Çünkü çok fazla
Türkiye üzerinden sordular. Erozyonu
sordular, heylanı sordular. Mesela geçen
sene çığ çıkacak demiştim. Özellikle son
soruda genel tekrarda çığ ile alakalı
soruyu çözmüştüm. Çağı çıkmıştı. Şimdi
heylan, erozyon, çığı, birçok şey
soruldu. Türkiye'den artık devam
edeceklerini düşünmüyorum. Etseler de
orman yangınını soracaklardır. O da
kolay zaten. Ama artık bir genel bir
tablo şöyle afetlerle alakalı bir tablo
ya da dünya üzerinde bir afet
sorulabilir. O yüzden şu tabloya dikkat
etmeni istiyorum. Bakın ne yapmışız.
Doğal olaylar sonucunda oluşmuş afet,
beşeri faaliyetler sonucunda oluşmuş
afet diye ayırmışız. iki ana kola
ayırmışız afetleri. Sonra bakın doğal
olaylar sonucunda oluşanların altında
jeolojik jeomorfolojik demişiz,
meteorolojik, klimatolojik demişiz,
biyolojik demişiz. Bu tabloyu böyle
ezberlemene gerek yok. Sen şimdi buradan
bir tane bildiğin bir tanesini ben eee
alayım. Mesela çığ. Çığ. Mesela çığı
bilirsin ne demek olduğunu. Şimdi çığı
sen getirip hangisine yerleştirirsin? E
hocam çığı kar yağacak. E o zaman
meteorolojik klimatolojik bir afet
dersin. Değil mi? Kaya düşmesi. Bak kaya
düşecek. E bu jeolojik jeorfolojik bir
şey. Kaya düşmesi havayla, klimayla,
iklimle alakalı değil ki. Yerle alakalı.
Jeo yer jeoyerdi. Jeoloji yer bilimiydi.
Jeomorfoloji yer şekilleriydi. Ha o
zaman bu kaya düşmesi yer şekilleriyile
alakalı dersin. Ha bak ne yaptın?
Aslında hangisinin nereye gireceğini sen
kendin belirleyebildin ama nasıl
belirledin? Ben sana bildiğin afetleri
söyledim. Çaığı bildiğin için
yerleştirebildin. Kaya düşmesini
bildiğin için yerleştirebildin. Ama sana
gelip tsunami dese. Tsunami. Ulan
tsunami ne diyorsun? He tsunamiyi
bilmediğin için o kelimeyi
yerleştiremedin. O yüzden ne yapacağız?
Şimdi ben sana bu afetleri tek
göstereceğim. Ondan sonra gelip bunun
altına tek yerleştireceğiz. Önce bilmen
lazım. Bildikten sonra gelip bunun
altına yerleştireceğiz. Tamam mı? Şimdi
o yüzden bu ana tabloyu dikkate alma.
İlk önce öğrenelim. İnşallah unutmazsam
tabloya geri dönmeyi. Tabloya her
kısımda, her öğrendiğimizde mesela
depremleri öğreneceğiz. Şimdi tabloya
geri döneceğiz. Şimdi depremler ve fay
hatları. Depremler nerede oluyordu?
Levha sınırlarında oluyordu. Değil mi?
Bizim levhalarımız vardı. Bu levhalar
bazı yerlerde birbirine yaklaşıyor. Bazı
yerlerinde birbirinden uzaklaşıyorlardı.
Bazen de yanal atım yapıyorlardı. Bu
leva sınırları aslında faylarımızdı.
Bizim kırık hatlarımızdı. Ve bu
kırıkların olduğu yerlerde de deprem
oluyordu. Aynı zamanda volkanizma da
burada oluyordu. Neden? Çünkü burada
kırık vardı, fay vardı. Dışarı lav
çıkıyordu. Volkanik faaliyetleri de
burada rastlıyordu. Burada sana
sorulacak soru. Bu fay hatını
çizebilmen. Şimdi şurada bir tersten
göstermiş bunu sana. Bu tersten
göstermeyi yapmadan önce bir de bunu
düzden görelim seninle. Nasıl çiziyorduk
deprem hatlarımızı biz? Amerika'nın bir
dakika alamadığım kalemi. Hah
kalınlaştıralım. Amerika'nın batısını
boydan boya çiziyorduk değil mi? Şöyle.
Amerika'nın batısını boydan boya
çiziyorduk. Sonra Avrupa içinden. Tabii
bu kalın bir çizgi gençler. Türkiye'den
Himalayalardan Endonezya'ya,
Endonezya'dan Yeni Zelanda'ya, Yeni
Zelanda'dan Japonya'ya. Gençler bakın bu
hattı çizmek ölüm kalım meselesidir
coğrafyada. Coğrafyada bir tane bilgi
öğrendirsen bu hattı çizmeyi öğren derim
sana. Başka Afrika'nın doğusundan kırık
geliyordu. Türkiye'ye doğru ulaşıyordu.
Bir de Atlas Okyanusu ortasından şöyle
İzlanda'ya doğru giden çizgi. Bu bizim
deprem bölgelerimiz. Şimdi bu deprem
bölgelerinin olduğu yerde o zaman ben ne
ararım? Bak burası levha sınırları.
Burası deprem hattı. Fay hatı kırık
bölgeleri. Aynı zamanda buralar
volkanizmanın da olduğu bölgeler. Aynı
zamanda sıcak su. Çünkü o kırıktan
aşağıya su gidiyordu. Kaynakları
öğrenmiştik ya. Fay hatlarını, fay
kaynaklarını. O sular oradan dışarı
çıkıyordu. O zaman buralarda sıcak su
kaynakları da var. Deprem hatlarının
olduğu yerde. Başka jeotermal kaynak.
Jeoyer. Jeoyer. Termal sıcak yerden
gelen sıcak su kaynakları buralarda. O
zaman bana sağlık turizmi kaplıca
dediğinde de buralarda arayacağım. Bakın
bir hattı bilmek bize ne kadar çok şey
kazandırdı. Şimdi ama bu hattı şöyle bir
dünya haritası verdiğinde ya hocam bu
dünya haritası ne deme. Bu dünya
haritası şu. Bakın şimdi gençler. Biz
normalde dünyaya nasıl bakıyoruz? Şurası
Amerika, Kuzey Amerika. Şurası işte
Avrupa, Afrika değil mi? Bu tarafta
Asya. Ama dünya küresel olduğu için biz
normalde haritayı böyle şurayı
düzleştirdiğimizi düşünün. Haritayı biz
böyle düzmüş gibi görüyoruz ama dünya
küresel. Arka tarafa bakın. Arka tarafta
aslında şurası Asya. E burası da
Amerika. Arka tarafta Bering'de, Bering
Boğazımız vardı burada. Bering'te
birleşiyordu bunlar, değil mi? Hatta
şuradaki Alaska burada Rusya'nın
toprağıydı. Sonradan Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'ne satmıştı bunu. Yani dikkat
edin dünya küresel olduğu için arkada
birleşik burası. Yani şuradan geldik ya
Endonezya'dan fay hattını getirdik.
Buradan Japonya'ya hattı uzattık. Hatta
Yeni Zelanda'ya uzattık az önce
sizlerken. Aslında bu hat arka tarafta
devam ediyor. Bakın bu hat devam ediyor.
Devam ediyor ve Amerika'nın batısından
aşağıya gelen o hat var ya aslında bu
hatla birleşik. Şimdi gelelim buraya.
İşte bu dünya haritası az önce
gördüğümüz Pasifik ateş çemberini yani o
arkada birleşmeyi sana daha güzel
gösterebilmek için oluşturulmuş, daha
farklı bir yerden gösterilmiş harita.
Mantığı anladın mı? O zaman burası şu
gördüğünüz yer. Bakın şuradan
Himalayalardan gelen Yeni Zelanda'ya,
Japonya'ya ve Amerika'nın batı kıyısına
doğru uzanan şu bölge Pasifik ateş
çemberi gençler. Dünyadaki depremlerin
büyük kısmı bu bölgede oluşuyor. Buraya
biz ne diyoruz? Pasifik ateş çemberi.
Anlaştık mı? Bakın büyük kısmından
kastımız ne? 5şte dü burada oluşuyor.
Başka Alp Himalaya deprem kuşağımız
vardı değil mi? Bakın Avrupa'nın
ortasından gelip Türkiye'den Himalaya
doğru gelen bu Alp Himalaya deprem
kuşağı. Bu da Pasifik'ten sonra ikinci
en büyük deprem kuşağı. Bir de Atlas
Okyanus'un ortasında vardı. Atlas
Okyanus'un ortasındaki bunlar kadar
güçlü depremi oluşturan bir kuşak değil.
Şimdi burada deprem çizgilerini
öğrendin. Aynı zamanda volkanların
nerede olduğunu da öğrendin değil mi?
Şimdi geldik şuraya. Rihter ölçeği.
Aslında biz bunları görmüştük ama tekrar
edelim. Depremler kısmını iç kuvvetlerde
öğrenmiştik gençler. Rihter depremlerin
büyüklüğünü ölçüyor. Bakın büyüklük işte
7.2 büyüklüğünde diyoruz ya. Ha onlar
büyüklük oluyor. Bir de Merkalli var. Bu
da şiddetini ölçüyor. Bazı depremler
gençler yerin farklı derinliklerinde
olduğu için ya da oraya evlerin yakın
olup uzak olmasına göre şiddeti farklı
olabiliyor. Deprem 7 büyüklüğünde
olabilir ama şiddeti yani yıkıcı gücü 8
büyüklüğünde olabilir. O yüzden Richter
aslında büyüklüğü ölçerken Merkalli
şiddetini ölçüyor. Bunu ben size böyle
örnek vermiştim. Hatırlayın. Silvri'de
oturuyorum ben şimdi. Ocakta Ankara'ya
taşınacağız inşallah. Stüdyoları açtık.
Burada mesela gitmeden bir deprem diye
yaşadım. Sağlam bir deprem. 6.2 da iki
büyüklüğünde miydi? Öyle bir şeydi
galiba. Normalde İstanbul'da hiçbir şey
olmadı ama biz çok hissettik Silivri'de
bunu. İstanbul bunu 4,5 hissetmişti
galiba. Biz 5çuğ'a yakın 5 5 buçğa yakın
Silivri. Çünkü bize yakındı depremin
olduğu yer. Merkeze yakındık. O yüzden
şiddet bizde daha fazla hissedildi.
Anlaştık mı mantığı? Evet. Depremin
etkileri e insan can ve mal kaybına
neden olur. Köprüler yıkılır, binalar
yıkılır, ulaşım yolları hasar görür.
Bunları rahatlıkla çıkartabileceğiniz
etkiler. Bunlar elektrik, su, doğalgaz
hatları zarar görür. Bunları
çıkartırsınız. Burada önemli olan şu
gençler. Depremler sonrasında bölgeden
göçler yaşanır. Bunu yaşadık biz
ülkemizde. Birçok insan göç etmek
zorunda kaldı, değil mi? Ülkemizdeki
diğer şehirlere. Burada bir diğer de
asıl önemli olan şunu unutmayın. Bakın
depremler tsunamilere, çağılara, kütle
hareketlerine hatta yangınlara bile
neden olabilir. Yangınlar daha az
görülse de mesela çığa neden olur
deprem. Bunu unutma. Bak burası önemli.
Mantıken düşüneceksin ama
ezberlemeyeceksin. Çığ ne? E kar kütlesi
kayıp gelecek. Deprem olduğunda bir
sallanma olur. E kar kayıp gelirdi mi?
Bak çığa neden oldu. Kütle hareketleri,
heylanlar, az sonra göreceğiz. Dağın
kopup gelmesi, dağdaki kayaların
gelmesi. Deprem olunca kayalar kayar
gelir değil mi? Bak depremleri kütlü
hareketlerine neden olur. Tsunamiye
neden olur deprem. Az sonra tsunamiyi
görürken göreceğiz. Tsunami dalgaların
kabarıp kıyıya vurması. Su su geliyor.
Denizde deprem olduğunda o dalgaların
kabarmasına neden oluyor. Demek ki
depremler tsunamiye neden oluyor? Bunu
unutmayın. Bu sana sorulduğunda ezbere
cevap vermeyeceksin. Oturacaksın. Ha,
tsunami suyu kabarmasına neden olabilir
diyeceksin. Hatta gelin o zaman
tsunamiye geçelim. Bakın hızları saatte
8 kmreyi, boyları 30 metreyi bulan
dalgalar. Bunlar denizde büyük dalgalar
oluyor. Bunların filmlerini
görmüşsünüzdür. Tabii illa böyle 30
metre olunca buna tsunami diyoruz. Böyle
değil. 35 metre olduğunda da aslında
tsunami özelliği bunlar kazanıyor.
Burada dikkat edin. Tsunami olmadan önce
gençler denizde geri çekilme olur. Bir
gün tsunami yaşarsak ülkemizde dikkat
edin buna. Hocam bizim ülkemizde tsunami
olur mu? Olur. Az sonra göstereceğim.
Geçmişte de olmuş. Peki bu tsunamiye
büyük dalgaların oluşmasına neden olan
şey ne gençler? Konuşmakta biraz
zorlanıyorum. E dilimde yara var ama
kampızda iki gün bir ik günlük gecikme
yaşandı. Daha da gecikmesin diye yaranın
iyileşmesini bekleyemeyeceğim. Arada
böyle peltekleşebilirim. Kusura bakmayın
yani şu an can çekişerek aslında dersi
anlatıyorum. Tsunamiyi oluşturan
sebepler neler peki? Tsunami. Tu su
geliyor diye kodladık bunu. Dalga
geliyor yani. E o dalga nasıl oluşacak?
He deprem oluşacak. Suyun altında deprem
oluşacak. Tamam. Suyun altında sadece
deprem değil. Bakın volkanizma da
oluşursa tsunamiye neden olabilir. Yani
suyun altında bir patlama olduğunda o
suyun kabarmasına neden olabilir. Heylan
olduğunda. E heyland kopup gelmesi orada
da bir dalga oluşturacak değil mi?
olabilir. Çok istisnai de olsa bu çok
görülen bir durum değil. Dinozorların
olduğu dönemlerde hani o büyük meteor
gelip dinozorları yok etmişti ya o
dönemlerde olmuş mesela. Ama çok
istisnai bir durum da olsa hani bilelim
meteor düşmeleri de tsunamilere neden
olabilir. E düşünsenize okyanusa denize
devasa bir meteor düştüğünde büyük büyük
tsnamilere neden olabilir mantıken. Peki
hocam şu harita bak bizim için değerli.
Bizim için değerli olan harita bu. Bunu
sorarlarsa bunu soracaklar bize ve bunu
sorarlarsa ve Türkiye'yi işaretlerse o
zaman bu senenin sınav sorusu olsun. Bu
size bir net vereyim artık şuradan artık
çıksın. Geçen sene de çıkacak demiştim.
Geçen sene çıkmamıştı bu. Bu sene 2026
ya da 2027 diyelim. Bu bizim sorumuz
olsun. Tsunami. Tsunami olması için ne
lazımdı? Deprem lazımdı, değil mi? O
zaman deprem bölgelerine yakın yerlerde
ararım tsunamiyi. Bak tsunamiyi bulmak
çok kolay. Deprem çizgilerine yakın
olacak. E bakın yukarıdan aşağıya
çiziyorum. Siyahla çizelim. Bak deprem
çizgisi. Görüyor musunuz? Tsunami
olabilir buralarda. Şurada biraz daha
şöyle arkada arkaya kaydığı için deprem
çizgisi. O yüzden şurada biraz daha
azdır. Ama sonuç olarak şurayı
alabiliriz böyle. Tamam. Bak bunlar
kırmızı zaten. Pasifik ateş çemberi
dediğimiz şu bölge zaten kırmızı. Zaten
bunun devamı buradan geliyordu. Değil
mi? Dikkat edin. Avrupa'dan gelen
Türkiye üzerinden Himalaya hattımız
vardı bizim. Buralarda da tsunami
yaşanabiliyor. Yani Türkiye'ye bakın.
Türkiye kırmızı gençler. Lütfen buna
dikkat edin. Türkiye tsunami riskinin
yüksek olduğu yerlerden bir tanesidir.
Bakın Yunanistan, Ege, Marmara buralar.
Akdeniz buralar gençler tsunami riskinin
Türkiye'de yüksek olduğu yerlerdir.
Dünyada Türkiye tsunaminin, tsunami
riskinin yüksek olduğu bir yerdir. Biraz
bakın buralarda Avrupa kısmında biraz
var. Buralar biraz daha sarıya dönüyor.
Neden sarıya dönüyor? Atlas Okyanusun
ortasından geçen bu çizgi bakın buralara
biraz daha uzaklaştığı için kırmızı
değil de uzak ya biraz daha sarı gibi.
Buralara da gençler burada yaşanan
depremlerden bu tarafa doğru bir tsunami
gerçekleşebiliyor. Demek ki bir Pasifik
ateş çemberini çizeceğim. İkincisi biraz
buralardan gelebilecek tsunami var.
Biraz da buradan gelebilecek bir tsunami
var. Tamam. Ve Türkiye'yi kesinlikle
alıyorum. Biraz da Avrupa'nın şu batı
kısmını. Bunu bize böyle direkt
işaretliyorlar. Bakın Afrika'da
Afrika'nın şu kısımlarında böyle bir
risk görülmüyor. Amerika'nın şu güney
kısımlarında, Güney Amerika'nın doğu
kısımlarında, güneydoğu kısımlarında
böyle bir risk görülmüyor. Bakın kuzeyde
böyle bir risk yok. Tamam. Türkiye'de
ama riskli bölgelerden bir tanesi. Evet.
Etkileri ne olacak? Kıyılar deniz suyu
altında kalır. Can ve mal kayıplarına
neden olabilir. Binalar yıkılır. Bunlar
yorumlayabileceğimiz şeyler. E tarım
alanı zarar görür. Ticari işletmeler
zarar görür. Turistik tesisleri zarar
görür. Bu kolay. Şimdi volkanizmayı da
öğreteyim. Sonra üstteki tabloya
gelelim. Tamam mı? Volkanizma. E az önce
biz deprem hatlarını gördük. Deprem
çizgilerinin olduğu yerde oluşacak demek
ki volkanik faaliyetlerde. Bakın Pasifik
ateş çemberi. Pasifik ve ateş çemberi
ağırlıklı olarak volkanizmanın etkileri
e cam mal kaybına neden olacak. Burada
dikkat etmenizi istediğim bir şey var.
Bunları yorumlarsın. Tarım alanı zarar
görür. Çevre sorunları artar. Tsunamiyi
az önce gördük. Tsunamilere neden
olabiliyordu volkanizma. Burada belki
yorumlayamayacağın şu bilgiye dikkat
edelim. Havaolunda ulaşımın aksamasına
neden olur. Volkanlar patladığında çok
ciddi kül de atıyorlar dışarı. Sonra
bunlar tüfe dönüşüyordu. Hani o
küllerden dolayı havaolu ulaşımı sekteye
uğrayabiliyor. Ben üniversitedeyken
İzlanda'daki volkan patlamıştı.
Avrupa'da bir haftaya yakın seferler
yapılamamıştı. Uçak seferleri. Tamam.
Şimdi gelelim en baştaki tablomuza.
Şimdi bak sen neyi öğrendin? Depremi,
tsunamiyi ve volkanik patlamayı
öğrendin. Şimdi deprem yerden gelmiyor
mu? Şimdi sen depreme hangisi hangi
gruba koyacaksın? Meteoroloji havayla mı
alakalı deprem ya da klimatoloji iklimle
mi alakalı deprem? Hayır. Gücünü nereden
alıyor deprem? Yerden alıyor. Peki
volkan patlaması gücünü nereden alıyor?
E da yerden alıyor. Peki asıl sorunun
dikkat etmen gereken kısmı burası.
Tsunami. Tsunami nereden alıyor? Nasıl
oluşuyordu hocam? Deprem oluyordu yerin
altında. Volkanizma oluyordu yerin
altında. E bunlar jeolojik jeorfolojik
bir şey. Jeolojik değil mi? Yerden
gelmiyor mu bunlar? E yerden geliyorsa
tsunamiye neden olan şey o zaman tsunami
dalga gelse bile dalgayla alakalı bile
olsa oluşumu yerden geldiği için
jeolojik jeomorfolojiktir. Buradan ben
olsam bu soruyu sorarım. Demek ki
tsunami jeolojik jeomorfolojik afetler
grubunda. Uzun zamandır böyle bir
afetleri böyle sıralamıyorlar. Lütfen
tsunamiyi buraya koymayı unutmayalım.
Anlaştık mı? Tsunami demek ki jeolojik
jeomorfolojik afet. Şimdi gelelim
jeolojik jeomorfolojiklerde diğerlerini
de öğrenelim. Burada diğerlerinden
kastım tüp hareketleri. Bunlar ne?
Heylan, kaya düşmesi, çamur akıntısı.
Daha çok böyle bir yamaç var. Yamacın
dengesi bozulunca bunlar oluşuyor.
Bunlardan ilki ve en önemlisi ÖSYM'de
heyvanı sormaya bayılır. Siz de ısrarla
bir türlü öğrenemezsiniz bunu. Aslında
çok basittir. Kodlamasını düşündüğün
zaman, "Hey lan, hey lan gelme
diyeceksin. Bak hey lan hey lan gelme.
Lan! Bak yarısı komuş gelmiş. Görüyor
musun? İşte bu hey lan. Sen bunu gidip
erozyonla karıştırıyorsun. Az sonra
erozyonda da göstereceğim sana.
Karışacak hiçbir şey yok. Hey lan. Hey
lan. Gelme dağın. Yarısı kopmuş. Gelmiş
bu kadar. Hey lan bu toprak kayması. Bak
bunu nerede arayacaksın diyor dünyada.
Türkiye'dekini ayrı işleyeceğiz bu
arada. Yani şu dünyadakileri görelim.
Afetleri öğren. Tabloyu öğren. Bu dersin
son kısmına doğru da Türkiye'yi
göstereceğim sana. Dünyada bak nerede
diyor bak. Kayalık dağları, Ant dağları,
Himalaya dağları, Heylan'ın en çok
olduğu yerler. Neden? E bak şimdi. E
şimdi şuralar Kayalık Dağları. E buralar
dağlık bölge heylan olacak burada. Başka
ne olacak? Bak Ant dağları. Buralar
dağlık olduğu için heylan oluyor. E en
fazla e bak Himalaya dağlarına geldik. E
şurada heylan olmasında nasıl dağın
yarısı kopup gelmesinde ne olsun? Demek
ki dünyada en fazla buralarda
görülüyormuş. Şimdi heylanın nedenleri
bize bunu soruyorlar işte gençler. Bunun
mantığını kavrayacaksın. Şimdi heylan
araziyi gözünün önüne canlandırman
lazım. Bu maddeleri ezberlemeyeceksin.
Araziyi gözünün önünde canlandıracaksın.
Nasıl? Dağın yarısı kopup geliyor. Nasıl
kopup geliyor? Bir burası dağlık
engebeli. Düz olsa olur mu? Düz olsa lan
nasıl olsun? Dağın yarısı kopup gelecek.
E düz yerde kopup gelemez ki. Ha demek
ki temelde burası eğimli bir arazi
olacak. Her eğimlide de kopup gelir mi?
Hayır. Nasıl oluyor? Bu eğimli arazi
gençler. Şöyle bu suyu çok yağmur yağ da
yer olacak burada. Su da olacak. Tamam
mı? Yani suyu iyice çekecek. Arazi suyu
çekecek. Çekecek çekecek. Çekecek
çekecek. Suya doyacak. Bu yağmur da
olabilir ama bak şunu da unutmayın. Kar
erimesi de olabilir. Kar çünkü kar kış
olan Erzurum'da mesela heylan yaşanıyor.
Çünkü kar erimesinin etkisi var. Sonra
toprak suya iyice doydu. Doydu doydu mu?
Bir de gençler bu arazide şu alt kısımda
bir kil tabakası varsa arazinin altında.
Kill ne demek? Hani şu çanak çömlek
yapılan çeviriyorsunuz da şekil
veriyorsunuz ya böyle. O çömleklerin
yapıldığı o kaygan. O değil mi? Kaygan
bir şeye şekil veriyor insanlar böyle.
Hani işte o kaygan. Suyu yiyince
kayganlaşıyor. Şimdi bir de bu aşağıda
kil tabakası varsa şöyle suyu 7 7 yedi.
Bir de kil tabakası var aşağıda. O
üstündeki büyük yer hop o kil
tabakasının üstünden kayıp gitti. İşte
Heylan'ın ana temel nedenleri bunlar.
Bir de eğer tabakalar eğilim
doğrultusunda uzanıyorsa bak hep bu
cümleye düşüyorsunuz. Soruları
yapamamanızın nedeni bu oluyor. Benim
gibi elinle somutlayacaksın. Bak şimdi
kil tabakası var dedik ya. Tabakalar
eğim doğrultusunda uzanıyorsa eğim böyle
tabakalarda eğimin doğrultusunda
uzanıyorsa aynı doğrultuda o zaman ne
yapar? Kayıp gider. Gördünüz mü?
Tabakalar eğim doğrultusunda uzanıyorsa
kayıp gitti. Ama eğime dik uzanıyorsa
eğim böyle eğime dik uzanıyorsa kayması
zor olur değil mi? He sana eğim
doğrultusunda uzanma, eğime dik sürme,
eğime paralel sürme gibi şeyler
söylediğinde böyle somutlayacaksın. Eğim
doğrultusunda uzanıyorsa kayıp gider.
Başka tabakalar eğimi söyledik. Deprem.
E şimdi burada suyu yemiş, yemiş, yemiş,
yemiş. Arazi şişmiş. Deprem olsa ne
olacak? Kayması çok kolaylaşır, değil
mi? Evet. Başka? Deprem de demek ki
etkiliyormuş bunu. Unutmayın deprem
önemli burada. Başka? Yol bina köprü
yapımı. Ne demek? Arazi böyle şimdi suyu
yemiş, yemiş, yemiş, yemiş, yemiş. Sen
de geliyorsun bu arazinin dengesini
bozuyorsun. Yani zaten zar zor duruyor
orada. Arazi kaymak için bahane arıyor.
Sen de geliyorsun orada yol
yapılıyorsun. Gürültü yapıyorsun,
titreşim yapıyorsun, kazıyorsun orayı
bayağı ciddi ciddi arazinin dengesini
bozuyorsun. Hop! Arazi kayıp gidiyor.
Heylan olabiliyor. Yol, köprü yapımı
gibi, bina yapımı gibi insan
faaliyetleri arazi dengesini
bozabiliyor. Tamam. ÖSYM 2ü yıl önceydi.
MSU'de böyle bir soru da sormuştu ve eee
şunu almıştı içine. Dikkat edin. Ben çok
kabul etmesem de bu bilgiyi ÖSYM böyle
almıştı. Ağaçları keserseniz heylana
neden olabilirsiniz demişti. Yani ağacı
kesince arazinin dengesini bozduğunuz
için dedi heylanı tetikleyebilir bu
dedi. Bana göre bir faydası, bir etkisi
olacağını düşünmüyorum ben. Çünkü kökten
kesmiyorsunuz. Yani kökünü
çıkartmıyorsunuz ki araziyi bozasınız.
Arazinin üstünde yani bunu sonuçta şu
kadar bir yerden kesiliyor ya ağaçlar.
Sıfırdan bile kesseniz ağacı kökü orada
duruyor. Bir bozulmaya neden olduğunu
düşünmüyorum ama ÖSYM bunu böyle kabul
etmişti. Sizin de aklınızda bulunsun.
Ağaçlar kesildiğinde heyranı
tetikleyebiliyor bu durum. Tamam. Buraya
kadar tamam mıyız gençler? Diğeri de
kütle hareketlerinde kaya düşmesi.
Dağlardan aşağıya doğru kaya düşmesi.
Bak bir kütle hareket ediyor. Ya da
çamur akıntısı. Ani yağaçlar oldu. Bir
anda bir çamur akıntısı yaşanıyor
arazide. Şu şekilde. Bakın bununla
alakalı videolar çıkmıştır önünüze.
Suyla beraber böyle bir çamur akıntısı
geliyor. Bu çamur akıntısı, kaya
düşmesi, heylan ne? Kütle hareketleri.
Şimdi gelelim bizim bu kısma. Bak neyi
gördük biz şimdi? Deprem, tsunami,
volkan patlaması, heylan, kaya düşmesi,
çamur akıntısı. Bunlar ne? Jeolojik,
jeomorfolojik. Bak dikkat et. aslında
jeolojik yer şekilleri ile alakalı.
Jeomorfolojik değil mi? Yer
şekillerinden dolayı oluşmuş. Kaya
düşmesi yer şeklinden, çamur akıntısı
yer şeklinden dolayı oluşuyor. Bunlar
unutma çamur akıntısı jeolojik
jeorfolojik bir afet bunlar. Bir de
şurada tsunami. Tsunami jeolojik. Suyun
geldiğine bakmayın tamam mı? Şimdi devam
edelim. Neredeyiz? Erozyondayız.
Bak senden rica ediyorum. Heylan'la
erozyonu karıştırıyorsun. Karıştıracak
hiçbir şey yok. Az önce heylanı gördük
biz değil mi? Hey lan denildiğinde
aklına ne gelecekti? Hey lan gelme.
Dağın yarısının kopup gelmesiydi. Hey
lan gelme. Şimdi bak hiç panik yap.
Erozyont. Erozyon hocam yanlış
söylediniz herhalde. Hayır sen ne
diyeceksin her zaman bu erozyona? Ero
diyeceksin. Bunu dediğinde bütün olay
çözülüyor. Nasıl? Ero yont. Toprağın
üstünün yontulması. Yani su geldi
toprağın üstündeki o ince toprağı aldı
götürdü. Rüzgar geldi toprağın üstünü
yonttu. Bak heylanla erozyont bambaşka
şeyler aslında. Heylan. Heylan gelme.
Kocaman bir kütlenin gelmesi. Erozyon.
Toprağın üstünde tozlar var. Toprağın
üstündeki o minerallerin, tozların
rüzgarla mesela taşınması. Hani rüzgar
esiyor da tozlar geliyor ya bize. Mesela
erozyon yaşanıyor o ara. Toprağın üstü
yontuluyor. Erozyont ikisi başka şeyler.
He buradaki kavramdan bu ayrımı
çıkarttıysan şimdi bir de görsel olarak
kafana kazı. Erozyont olması için bir
kurak yer düşüneceksin. Neden? Toprağın
üstü çıplak olacak ki toprağın üstünü
yontabilelim. Mesela Karadeniz'de her
taraf çayır çimen, her tarafta ağaçlar
var. Değil mi? Sen orada toprağın üstünü
yontabilir misin? Hayır. Erozyont
denildiğinde bu görsel gelecek aklına.
Erozyont. Toprağın üstünün yontulması.
Bu görsel geldiğinde ve o kelimeden
kodlamayı çıkarttığında iş çok basit.
Neden? Nedenlerine bak şimdi. Erozyonun
nedenleri. Erozyontun nedenleri. Erozyon
kurak olacak toprağın üstünde. Şimdi
bitki örtüsünü tahrip edersen, bitki
örtüsünü kaldırırsan toprağın üstünden
aa toprak açığa çıkar. O zaman erozyon
ortaya çıkar. Toprağın üstü yontulur o
zaman. Bak bu kadar somutladım. Yorum
yapıyorum. Aşırı otlatma ve meraların
bozulması ne demek? Yani şu mera ne?
Meralar hayvanların otlatıldığı çayırlık
alanlar değil mi? Siz şimdi toprağın
üstündeki çayırlık alanı otlatırsanız,
aşırı otlatırsanız düşünün çayırlar var.
Hayvanları aşırı otlattım. E çayırlar
gitti. Toprak çıplak kaldı. Aa bak
toprak çıplak kalırsa üstü süpürülür
götürülür üstü yontulur. Eroz yont olur.
Toprağın üstü yontulur. Demek ki aşırı
otlatırsak toprağın üstü yontulur.
Şiddetli yağışlar ve rüzgarlar. Şimdi
bir anda yağmur yağdığını düşünün.
Toprağın üstünü yontulup götürülmesi
kolay olur değil mi? Aynı şekilde
şiddetli rüzgar eserse toprağın üstünün
yontulmasına neden olur. Bak sadece
somutlayarak nasıl yorum yapıyorum? E bu
bölge nasıl bölge olması lazım? Toprağın
üstünün yontulabilmesi için kurak yarı
kurak bölge olması lazım. Eğer Karadeniz
gibi yağışlı bir bölgeyse e orada çayır
çimen olur o zaman toprağın üstü
yontulamaz ki. Ha demek ki eroz yont
kurak yarı kurak bölgelerde oluyor.
Toprağın çıplak olduğu yerlerde bitki
örtüsünün olmadığı yerlerde toprağın bir
de gençler gevşek yapıda olması. Toprak
böyle gevşekse rüzgar su alıp götürmek
daha kolay olur ama böyle daha sıkıysa
götürmek daha zorlaşır. Bak şu an
ezberlemiyorsun bunları. Ben sana nasıl
yorum yapacağını öğretiyorum. Bunları
nasıl yorumlayacağını. Sen de bilgiyi
sana soru sorulduğunda somutlayacaksın
beyninde. Ero yontrağın üstünün
yontulması. Böyle olursa şöyle olur.
İşte bitki olmazsa toprak çıplak kalır o
zaman yontulur gibi yorumu kendin
yapacaksın. Amacımız bilgiyi nasıl
üreteceğini öğretmek. Öğretmenlik
dediğimiz şey de budur. Anlatmakla
öğretmenin farkı budur. Sen de ne
yapacaksın? Bilgiyi nasıl öğreneceğini
öğreniyorsun şu an. Bu açıdan bak
bunları ezberlemeye kalkarsan biz hata
yapıyoruz demektir. Sen ha yapıyorsun,
yanlış çalışıyorsun demektir. Ben sana
nasıl yorumlayacağını gösterip bilgiyi
nasıl üreteceğini gösteriyorum. Sen de
karşına soru çıktığında bilgiyi üretmeyi
öğren. Tamam. Yanlış ve bilinçsiz toprak
işleme yöntemi. Nasıl yani hocam?
Toprağı mesela eğime dik sürmek. Şey
pardon eğime paralel sürmek. Bak şimdi
eğim böyle. Eğime paralel sürersem ne
olur? Toprağın kaymasını, yontulmasını
kolaylaştırırım, değil mi? Ama toprağı
tarım yaparken eğime dik sürersem, bak
eğim dik sürdü. He bak bu o kadar
toprağı kaydırmıyor. Bu iyi bir şey ama
eğime paralel sürersen toprak kayıp
gider. Yontulması yani toprağın
yontulması kolaylaşır. Bunu unutma.
Yangınlar da etkili. Bakın yangın olursa
toprağı koruyan bitki gider. Bitki
giderse erozy ortaya çıkar. Ormanları
tahrip edersek mesela orman var burada.
toprağın yontulmasını engelliyor. Ormanı
tahrip edersem aa toprak çıplak kalır.
Yontulması kolaylaşır. Peki ağaç
dikersem erozyonu engelleyebilir miyim?
Evet. Neden? Şimdi toprak çıplak.
Buralara ağaç diktiğimizi varsayalım. Ne
olur? Rüzgarın ve suyun toprağın üstünü
yontmayı yontmasını engelleyebiliriz.
Yavaşlatabiliriz ya da demek ki ağaç
dikmek erozyon için önemli. Evet. Peki
hocam bu erozyon neden bu kadar
tehlikeli bir afet? Gençler, erozyont
şundan dolayı tehlikeli. Toprağın en
verimli kısmı, en üstteki kısmıdır. O
küçük küçük rüzgarın taşıdığı, suyun
taşıdığı verimli. Asıl orasıdır verimli.
Şimdi siz yağmurla beraber toprağın üstü
hep böyle yıkanır giderse ne olur?
Toprağın asıl verimli kısmı yıkanır
gider ve toprak aslında verimsizleşir.
Toprak verimsizleşirse de toprak
çoraklaşır. İnsanlar artık tarım
yapamazlar. Kıtlık başlar. İnsanlar göç
etmek zorunda kalır. Bakın ne kadar
tehlikeliymiş demek ki erozyt. Heylan
hızlı gelişti bak dikkat edin. Bazı
sorularda bu sorulur bize. Heylan bak
daha yarısının kopup gelmesiydi değil
mi? Heylan gelme. Erozyont. Erozyon
yavaş yavaş toprağın üstü yavaş yavaş
yontulur. Yıllarca yavaş yavaş yontulur,
yontulur, yontulur. Yavaş gerçekleşen
bir afettir. Erozyont yavaş gerçekleşir
ama kıtlığa neden olur. İnsanların göç
etmesine neden olur. Çok ciddi
tehlikeleri vardır. Açlığa neden olur. O
yüzden erozyont engellememiz lazım
bizim. Erozyontu ağaç dikerek
engelleyebiliriz. Heylanı ağaç dikerek
engelleyebilir misin? Engelleyemezsin.
Evet. Bakın toprak verimsizleşir. Göçler
artar. Etkilerine bakın. Toprak
verimsizleşir. Göğleri artar. Kıtlık
bitki çeşitliliği azalır. Barajların su
tutma kapasitesi azalır. Bu ne demek
şimdi? Barajların su tutma kapasitesi şu
bu arada tabloya gelelim. Şöyle.
Barajların su tutma kapasitesi yorumu
önemli gençler. Barajlar akarsuyun
önündeki setlerdir. Değil mi? Şimdi
akarsu alivyon taşıyordu değil mi? Delta
ovalarına alivyon getiriyordu. Yani bu
alivyonlar verimli topraklardı. Deltalar
da bu yüzden verimliydi. İşte o verimli
toprak getiriyor dediğimiz toprakları
erozyon sonucunda çevreden toplayıp
götürüyor. Arkadaki bütün araziyi
verimsizleştiriyor. Getirip onu deltaya
getiriyor. Delta verimli oluyor ama
arkadaki arazisi verimsizleşiyor. Hatta
çok daha kötü bir şey var. Belki bunu
deltaya bile götüremiyor. Nereye
götürüyor? E baraj var. Barajın barajı
geçebiliyor mu o toprak? Barajın geldiği
yerde baraj bir set gibi o toprağı orada
tutuyor. Barajların altı böyle çamurdur,
balçıktır. Barajlar gençler ilk
yapıldıktan sonra o topraklarla dolmaya
başlar, dolmaya başlar, dolmaya başlar,
dolmaya başlar. Uzun yıllar sonra, 5060
yıl sonra artık barajda su tutma
kapasitesi iyice azalır. Yani geçmişte
baraj buradan buraya kadar su tutarken
zamanla çamurla, toprakla, toprakla
dolar dolar artık sadece şu kadar su
tutabilir. Barajların su tutma
kapasitesi azaldı. Bakın neden? Çünkü
akarsu erozyon sonucunda getirdiği
çamurları getirdi. Barajını oraya yığdı.
Bunu unutmayın. Şimdi gelin size ben
olsam asıl soracağım ikinci soruyu
söylüyorum. Birincisi tsunamiyi
sorardım. İkincisi de biyolojik afetleri
sorardım. Biyolojik afet
sınıflandırmasını sorardım. Ya var ya şu
soru çıkarsa biyolojik afet
sınıflandırması ve sınavda kulağınızda
çınlamazsa kulağınızı çekerim. Sınavdan
çıktıktan sonra da bunu Yunus Hoca
söyledi diye tek tek hepiniz
söyleyeceksiniz. Çünkü bu böyle sorulan
bir soru değil. Hiç sağda solda hiçbir
yerde olan bir soru da değil. Size nokta
atışı söylüyorum. Bakın biyolojik afer
çıkma ihtimali çok yüksek sorudur. Bunu
söylememin nedeni de kafamdan
sallamıyorum. OM materyaldeki soruları
analiz etmiştim zamanında ve bununla
alakalı 34 tane soru görmüştüm ama
bununla alakalı hiç soru gelmedi.
Afetlerde ciddi anlamda soru sorulmuştu
OGEM materyalde, devletin sorduğu
sorularda ama hiç çıkmadı. O yüzden
bakın Erozyonta bakın. Nerede gençler?
Erozyon. Eroont biyolojik afetler
kısmında. Neden biyolojik afet sorusunu
bilmesem de cevabını bilmesem de
araştırdım. Tam kafamda oturmuyor ama
erozyont biyolojik afet sınıfında. Biraz
araştır sana bırakıyorum bunu. Neden
biyolojik afet grubuna girdiğini öğren.
Yorumlara yaz. Beni bakalım ikna
edebilecek misin? Dikkat edin gençler.
Buraya bir tane daha var burada. Orman
yangınları da biyolojik afet. Ya şu soru
sorulsa var ya kimse yapamaz biliyor
musunuz? Hele de bunu öncüllü sorsalar 1
2 3 4 diye, yukarıdakilerden hangisi
biyolojik afet grubuna girer diye. Size
yemin ediyorum ya bu soru da neymiş
böyle soru mu olur? Türkiye'nin herhalde
%90'ı yapamaz bu soruyu. O yüzden çok
böyle çeldirici bir kısım var burada.
ÖSYM böyle çeldiricileri sormayı sever.
Ne yapacaksın? Erozyon ve orman
yangınları biyolojik afettir. Orman
yangını hadi ormanlar yanıyor canlılar
içerisinde falan. Buradan biyolojik
olduğunu belki yorumlayabiliriz. Dikkat
et bak. Salgın. Salgınlar zaten
biyolojiktir dersin. Böcek istilaları da
bakın biyolojik canlılarla alakalı.
Onları koymak kolay ama orman yangını
özellikle de erozy' buraya koymak çok
zordur. Bu tabloyu adın gibi öğren.
Tamam burası tamam mı? Devam edelim
gençler. Şimdi geldik burada tropikal
siklonlara. Bunları bunlar tropikal
siklonlar. Bu soru gençler soruluyor ve
şöyle bir durum var. Bu afetleri
öğrendiğinde aslında AYT'de çözeceğin
soruları da öğreniyorsun. Bu tropikal
siklonları sormuşlardı AYT'de. Geçen
seneydi galiba. 2025 değil 2024'tü
galiba. Ben TYT soru çözüm, son soru
çözüm videomda çözmüştüm. Bunu
denemelerimden seçmiştim. 45 soru
seçmiştim. TYT'de değil ama aynı o seçme
soru AYT'de çıkmıştı o sene. Bunu AYT'de
de sorabiliyorlar. Hatta bu afetleri
öğreniyorsunuz ya şu an. Büyük bir
ihtimalle AYT'den de soru
yakalayacaksınız burada. Şimdi tropikal
siklon adına bakın ezberlemeyin.
Kelimeye bak. Hep kelimeden bir şey
çıkartıyoruz. Bak hey lan. Hey lan
gelme. Dağın yarısı koptu. Geldi. Ero
yont. Ha yont. Toprağın üstünün
yontulması. Tsunami. Su su geliyor.
Dalga geliyor. Bak hep kelime. Tropikal
siklon. Tropikal. Aa tropikal bölgelerde
görülüyor bu demek ki. Aslında biz bunu
rüzgarlarda öğrenmiştik. Hatırla.
Tropikal siklonlar. Hani buradan
arizeler geliyordu. Döne döne döne döne
bak Amerika'ya vuruyordu. Bunu nereye
vurduğunu adın gibi bileceksin. Buradan
geldi mi? Bak Amerika'ya vuruyor ya ama
geniş geniş geliyor. E geniş geniş
gelirken Güney Amerika'nın kuzey
kısımlarına da buralara da vuruyor. Bak
dikkat et. Buradan geldi. Geniş geniş
geniş geniş çizeceksin. Amerika'yı böyle
alacaksın. Burası tamam. Bu tarafa
geliyorum. E buradan gelen çizgi aynen
buradan da gelecek. Karşı tarafı da
alacağım. Bak buradan bir çizgi çizdin.
Bir daha bak kodlaması bu. Buradan geldi
mi bu rüzgarı? Geniş geniş geldi. Burayı
vurdu. Bu tarafa geliyorum. E aynı
çizgide karşı taraftan da başlatacaksın.
Ariz rüzgarı tekrar geldi. Geldi. Geniş
geniş geniş geniş. Burayı vurdu. Nereyi
vurdu bakın şurada Hindistan kısımlarını
komple vurdu. Bunlar kuzeydeki Alize. E
bir de burada güneydeki Alize var. Bu
sefer bir tane de şöyle yapalım. Bu
kodlamayı böyle yapalım sizinle. Şurayı
tropikal siklon karşı tarafa bir çizgi
çizdik. Buradan aşağıya in diyelim.
Tamam. Buradan aşağıya indik. Burası da
bakın tak tak.
Şuraya doğru şu Afrika'nın şu kısmına
vuruyor. Tamam mı? Madagaskar adasının
bulunduğu şu kısma. Şu Avustralya'nın
kuzey kısımlarına da vurabiliyor. Şöyle
burayı da çizdim. Tamam mı? Bir tane
harita bulalım. Şuradan Arizeleri
getirdim. Geniş geniş geniş geniş geniş
geniş çizdim. Şuradan getirdim. Geniş
geniş geniş geniş geniş geniş
Hindistan'a doğru çizdim. Şuradan
Avustralya'nın kuzeyinden karşı tarafa
doğru bir çizgi çizdim. Tamam mı? Sen de
bir tane harita al karşına. Aynı şekilde
yap bunlara gençler. E bu kasırgalara
bazı yerlerde tropikal yani tropikal
siklonlar genel ismi bunun. Bunlara
kasırga, tornado, hurricane, vili vili
gibi çeşitli isimler verilebiliyor.
Bakın Türkiye'de böyle kasırgalar
görülmüyor. Tabii buradaki gibi çok
güçlü kasırgalar görülmüyor. İklim
değişimi ile beraber küçük de olsa
hortumlara rastlayabiliyoruz ama burada
tropikal siklonlardan bahsediliyor. Yani
bakın saatte 118120
kmrlerden bahsediyoruz. 60 ketrenin
üstüne çıkanlardan bahsediyoruz. Tamam.
Bunlar nerede bak? Tropikal çevrede. Bak
adını nereden alıyor? Tropikal, tropikal
bölge bak burası. Tamam mı? Burası
tamam.
>> Eşit etli rüzgarların başlıca etkileri.
Can, mal, eee, kayıplara neden oluyor.
Hayvanlara zarar veriyor. Evlere zarar
veriyor. Amerika'da yaşanan bu
kasırgaları görmüşsünüzdür. Büyük
ekonomik kayıplara neden oluyor bu
arada. Amerika milyarlarca dolar zarar
ediyor bunlardan. Sel ve taşkınlar
gençler. Seller bakın ani yağışlar
oluyor. Kar erimeleri oluyor. Hiç
beklemediğiniz bir anda büyük su
akıntısı geliyor size doğru. Buna sel
diyoruz. Taşkınsa bak taşması lazım.
Akarsuyun yatağından taşmasına da taşkın
diyoruz. Sel ve taşkınları dünyada
nerede göreceğiz? Hiç bunu ezberlemene
gerek yok. Sel ve taşkın olması için
yağmurun fazla olması lazım. Kar
erimesinin olması lazım. Değil mi
gençler? Özellikle bu selve ve taşkınlar
bu güneydoğu Asya'da sık sık
rastlanıyor. Neden? Yağmurun fazla
olduğu bölge değil miydi burası? Yaz
mevsiminde durmadan yağmur yağıyordu. E
burada bir de Himalaya dağları var.
Himalayaların erimesiyle beraber bu
hindus gan nehirleri taşacak. Şurada
Bangladeş. Özellikle burada hem
yağmurlar hem kar erimeleri bütün bunlar
biriktiğinde Bangladeş burada çok
tehlikeli bölgelerden bir tanesi. Sevda
taşkınların olduğu alan. Şimdi burada
ciddi yağmur yağıyor Kongo'da. E Amazon
hafızasının bulunduğu bölgelerde yağmur
yağıyor. Yağmurun olduğu bölgelerde
yaşanacak Sel ve taşkınlar. Şimdi gelip
çölü işaretlediğinde sen sel ve taşkın
var diyebilir misin? Diyemezsin. Bu
mantıkla yapacaksın bunu. Tamam mı? Sel
ve taşkınların nedenleri. Bu video uzun
bir video oluyor çünkü çok kapsamlı bir
video. Ayrıntılı da anlatmaya
çalışıyorum sana. O yüzden sen de
dikkatli dinle. Tamam. Sev ve
taşkınların nedenleri. Pes etme. Bunun
da soru çözümünü kesinlikle
izleyeceksin. Şimdi burada gençler
bunları böyle yine ezberleme ya.
Mantıken bir düşün. Sel ve taşkın su
lazım bize. E o zaman bak aşırı ve ani
yağışlar. Sel ve taşkına neden olur mu?
Olur. E aşırı ani yağış olacak. Burada
belki unuttuğun ya da dikkatten
kaçıracağın kısım kar ve bu erimeleri.
Mesela bizim ülkemizde Erzurum'da çok
fazla sel ve taşkın yaşanıyor.
Türkiye'de en fazla Erzurum'da yaşanıyor
sel ve taşkın. Niye? Çünkü Erzurum'da
kar erimeleri çok fazla. E kar erimesi
ne zaman? İlkbahar yaza doğru. Değil mi?
E o zaman demek ki en fazla Sel ve
Taşkın Erzurum kısmında kar
erimelerinden dolayı ilkbahar ve yaza
doğru yaşanıyormuş. Bak ezberleme.
Burada gençler şiddetli fırtınalar.
Fırtınalar çünkü yağış da getirebiliyor
değil mi? Bu da sev ve taşkınlara neden
olabiliyor. Şunu unutmayın. Dere
yataklarını yerleşim bölgesi açılması.
Karadeniz'de mesela sellere çok
rastlanıyor, taşkınlara çok rastlanıyor.
Neden? Karadeniz'de insanlar böyle
vadilerin içerisine yerleşiyordu bir
tek. Çünkü o vadiler vardı yerleşim yeri
için. Çok sınırlıydı. Dağlık engebeliydi
Karadeniz. Şimdi ne oluyor? Sen dere
yatağına yerleşiyorsun. Eee, su bir yağ,
yağmur bir yağıyor. Kar bir eriyor, dere
yatağı taşıyor. Sel ve taşkınlara bizim
ülkemizde Karadeniz'de bu yüzden çok
fazla rastlanıyor. Nedeni dere
yataklarına yerleşim yapıyoruz biz
Karadeniz'de. Başka? E burada dere
yatağının değiştirilmesi de var.
Normalde dere buradan akıyor. Tamam mı?
İnsanlar bu dere yatağını çevirmişler
başka yere. Sonra dere bunu şey yapmaz,
affetmez. O kendi yatağını bulur akar.
Sonra bir gün bir yağmur bir geliyor.
Ha, bütün dere yatağını tekrar eski dere
yatağına geri dönüyor. Sen de eski dere
yatağına ev yapmışsın. Bütün evler alıp
götürüyor. Bitki örtüsünün tahribi de bu
sev ve taşkınlara neden olabiliyor.
Bitki örtüsü bu suyu tutabiliyor. Yer
altına sızmasını sağlayabiliyor. Eee,
bitki örtüsü olmadığı da sel ve taşkın
olma ihtimali artıyor. Altyapının
yetersiz olması büyük şehirlerde sel ve
taşkınlara neden oluyor. Bazı dönemlerde
görürsünüz haberlerde Ankara'da sel oldu
diye, İzmir'de sel oldu diye. Çünkü o
altyapı yetersizliği. Çünkü geçmişte
orası toprakmış. Suyu çekecek. E sen
şimdi her tarafı beton yaptın. E bu
betonlara bir kanalizasyon sistemi
yaptın. Ama kanalizasyon sistemi de
yeterli değil. Beton da suyu çekemiyor.
Yağan bütün yağmur seleniden oluyor.
Demek ki aslında büyük şehirler
şehirleşme de sel ve taşkınlarda etkili.
Tamam. Bunu unutmayın. Yine ne?
İnsanlara can ve mal kayıplara neden
oluyor. Sev ve taşkınlar etki olarak
yerleşim yerlerini tarım arazilerine
zarar veriyor. Ulaşıma zarar verebiliyor
altyapılara zarar veriyor. Bunlar yorum
yapabileceğiniz kısımlar. Ha bir de
burada kirli sular nedeniyle salgın
hastalıklar ortaya çıkabiliyor. Burası
tamam mıyız? Geldik çığa. Bunların
Türkiye versiyonlarını ben size az sonra
göstereceğim. Ders bitmiyor. İlk önce
genel görüyoruz. Sonra Türkiye
versiyonlarını göreceğiz. Tamam. Çığ ne?
Dağlık bölge olacak. Dağlık bölgede kar
kayıp gelecek. Değil mi? Çığ. Bize ne
lazım o zaman? Çığın olması için
engebeli ve eğimli bir yer lazım. Düz
yerde kar kayabilir mi gözünü seveyim? O
zaman bize dağlık bölge lazım. O zaman
sana bir dünya haritasında çığı çağı
nerede yaşanır diye sorduğunda. E sen
şimdi çığı gözünün önüne getireceksin.
Yav çığın çölde yaşanma ihtimali var mı?
Çığı nerede arayacaksın? Dağlık bölgede,
Himalaya dağlarında ararsın çığı,
Türkiye'nin dağlık bölgesinde ararsın
çığı, Alplerde ararsın mesela çığ
felaketini, değil mi? Gelirsin kayalık,
Ant dağlarında ararsın. Bunların bu
bilginin sana böyle direkt verilmesine
gerek yok. Sen yorum yapmayı biliyorsun.
Çığ nerede görülür? Dağlık bölge. E sen
Türkiye'deki dağların nerede olduğunu,
dünyadaki dağların nerede olduğunu
öğrendin. O zaman dünyada nerede dağılış
gösterdiğini de biliyorsun çığın. Bu
mantığı unutma. Bitki örtüsünden yoksun
arazilerde. Şimdi bitki örtüsü çığı
engelleyebilir mi? Düşün. E şimdi kar
yağmış ama her tarafta da ormanlar var.
He çığın yaşanma ihtimali daha az olur
değil mi? Bitki örtüsü gençler çığı
engelleyebilir. Bitki örtüsü olmazsa çığ
daha kolay, kar daha kolay kayar. Yol
yapım çalışmaları sırasında ses
yapıyoruz. E o zaman yani insanlar orada
bağırıp çağırdığında bile çığı kopuyor.
E yol yaparken çığı kopabilir. E deprem
yaşandı. E her taraf sallandı. Çığı
kopabilir. Volkan patlaması yaşandı. E
sallanma olacak. Depreme neden oluyordu
volkanik patlamalar? E o zaman çığı
olabilir. Araç ve insanın sesleri.
İnsanlar mesela son zamanlarda dikkat
edin kayak merkezlerinin bulunduğu
bölgelerde çığı yaşanabiliyor. Adam
mesela kayak pistinde değil de kayak
normalde pist olmayan yerin pistin yan
tarafında pist olmayan kısımlarda
kaymaya gidiyor. Oralarda önlem
alınmamış çığa neden olabiliyor. Bu sene
biz bunu bir iki defa gördük haberlerde.
Anlaştık mı? Evet. Çı orman yangınları
gençler ormanın olduğu yerde olacak.
Orman lazım bize. Dünyada bize
sorulduğunda büyük bir ihtimalle Akdeniz
iklimini ve tropikal bölgeyi soracak.
Orman yangının en fazla olduğu bölge
tropika. Tropikal yani ekvator.
Ekvatoral yağmur ormanlarının bulunduğu
o bölgeler tamam yağışlı bölgeler
buralar ama sonuçta orman var burada.
Orman yangını yaşanabilir burada. Daha
çok nerede yaşanır ama kuraklığın da
olduğu. Çünkü ekvator'da yağmur var ama
mesela Akdeniz ikliminde yağmur da yok.
Yani kuraklık var. Özellikle yazın
dünyada özellikle Akdeniz ikliminin
görüldüğü yerlerde orman yangınları çok
şiddetli yaşanıyor. Hatırlayın
İtalya'da, Fransa'da, Türkiye'de,
Avustralya'da, Amerika'da buralar
Akdeniz ikliminin bulunduğu bölgelerde
buralar şiddetli orman yangınlarının
yaşandığı yerlerdir gençler. Demek ki
orman yangını denildiğinde Akdeniz
iklimi biraz aklımıza gelecek
çoğunlukta. Tabii ki bunun dışında orman
varlığının olduğu yerleri de
işaretleyeceksin ama genelde Akdeniz
iklimidir. Çünkü Akdeniz iklimi yazları
kurak, su yok. Tamam. Akdeniz ikliminde
neler de görüldüğünde hani Afrika'nın
kuzeyinde Akdeniz'i çiziyorduk. Karşı
tarafa çizgi çiziyorduk. Afrika'nın en
kuzeyinden uç noktalara geliyorduk.
Değil mi? Buralar işaretlenecektir sana.
Orman yangınlarının nedenleri gençler
orman yangınlarının çok büyük bir kısmı
insan kaynaklı nedenlerden oluşuyor.
İnsan kaynaklıdan kastımız ne? Anız
yakıp çök çöp yakıyoruz biz. Anız yakmak
ne? Anız yakmak tarımdan sonra tarım
yapıldıktan sonra o samanın mesela alt
kısımları kalıyor ya toprakta kalan
bitki. Bitkiler tarım yapıldıktan sonra,
tarım ürünleri alındıktan sonra toprakta
kalan otlar. Bu otları insanlar
yakıyorlar daha çabuk toprağı
işleyebilmek için. Yakarken orman
yangını da ortaya çıkabiliyor. Anız
yaktığınızda toprağın üstündeki otları
yaktığınızda aslında erozyona da neden
oluyorsunuz. Toprak çıplaklaşıyor değil
mi? Bunu unutmayın. Bu bilgiyi. Çöp
yakma. Çöp yakarken de insanlar orman
eee orman yangınına neden olabiliyor.
Hatta bu sene çok ciddi orman
yangınlarıyla boğuştuk. Biz böyle 3
yılda bir çok ciddi orman yangınlarıyla
boğuşuyoruz. Bu sene de onlardan bir
tanesiydi. Büyük bir ihtimalle bu sene
de karşımıza orman yangını çıkacaktır.
Mesela adamın biri almış bir tane yatağı
mı ne varmış gitmiş ormana. Ormanda o
yatağı yakmaya kalkmış. Orman yangının
nedeni bu oldu. Bu sene avcılık
sırasında çıkabiliyor. Piknik
faaliyetleri bunda çok etkili. Piknik
yaparken çünkü o kadar kurak ki küçücük
bir alev hemen harlanıp gidebiliyor.
Piknik faaliyetleri sırasında ortaya
çıkabiliyor. Sigara izmaritleri yere
atıldığında özellikle Akdeniz kısmında
sigarayı yere atıyorsun. Hadi bakalım.
Zaten saman gibi yerde ot var. yanıp
gidiyor. İnsanların bilinçsizliği
aslında. Çevreye atılan cam şişeler, o
cam şişelerin mercek görevi görüp yangın
çıkartması, kasıtlı çıkarılan orman
yangınları. Bakın çoğu aslında insan
kaynaklı bunların. Meteor düşmesi insan
kaynaklı değil de ne kadar meteor
düşüyor? Hayvanların taşıması da bu
arada yani bir yerde bir alev oluyor ya.
Hayvanlar bu alev hayvanlar da yanıyor.
Koşayım derken ormanı daha da aleve
almasına neden oluyor. Yıldırım
düşmeleri orman yangınına neden
olabiliyor. Volkanik patlamalar gençler.
Volkanlar patladığında lav çıkıyor.
Bunlar da orman yangınına neden
olabilir. Tamam mı? Şimdi kuraklık yavaş
gerçekleşen bir afettir gençler.
Kuraklık hangi afetler yavaş, hangi
afetler hızlı? Bunu ezberlemeyeceksin.
Sana sorulduğunda deprem hızlı
gerçekleşiyor. İşte bir anda geliyor
vuruyor. Böyle volkan patlaması hızlı
gerçekleşiyor. Kuraklık yavaş
gerçekleşiyor. Nedir kuraklık? Bak ne
demiş. Bir havzaya düşen yağış
miktarının o havzada gerçekleşen
buharlaşma miktarından az olması. Yani 2
birim yağış düşüyor. 3 birim buharlaşma
var. Yağıştan çok buharlaşma var. E ne
oluyor? kuraklık ortaya çıkıyor.
Özellikle gençler hayvancılık
faaliyetleri ve tarım faaliyetleri böyle
kurak yarı kurak bölgelerde iklimlerin
olduğu yerlerde mesela İç Anadolu'da
bizim Güneydoğu Anadolu'da kuraklık çok
şiddetli Güneydoğu Anadolu'da neden
tarım yapılıyor? Hayvancılık yapılıyor
sıcak bölge zaten. Su buharlaşıp
gidiyor. İnsan faaliyetleri kuraklığı
daha da fazla tetikliyor. Bakın dünyada
en fazla yaşandığı yer Afrika Sahra
Çöl'nün güneyinde kalan Senegal Somali.
Aslında burası biraz daha savan bölgesi
dediğimiz kısım. Nedenleri neler? Su
kaynaklarının azalması ve kuruması.
Ülkemizde de birçok yerde su kaynakları
azalıp kuruyor. Doğal bitki örtüsünü yok
ettiğinizde bu da kuraklığa neden
oluyor. Çünkü bitki örtüsü suyu toprakta
tutmayı sağlıyor. Bitki örtüsünü yok
ettiğinizde buharlaşma artı. Bak
kuraklığa neden oldu. Tarım hayvancılık
faaliyetleri az önce söyledim. Mesela
Güneydoğu Anadolu'da barajlardan gelen
su salma sulama yapılıyor. Her tarafa
böyle salınıyor. Su e sıcak bölge burası
zaten. Çöl gibi yer. Bir anda suyu
salıyorlar. Buharlaşıp gidiyorsun.
kuraklar neden oluyor. Etkilerinde bak
suyumuz kalmıyor, bitkimiz kalmıyor,
üretim düşüyor. Etki olarak bakarsak can
kaybına neden olur. Kurak su insan
açlıkla boğuşacak. Su yetersiz kalacak.
İçme suyu. Bu sene ülkemizde de bunu
yaşadık. Bazı yerlerde belediyeler su
veremez hale geldi. Göçler yaşanacak bu
yüzden. Hidroelektrik üretimimiz
düşecek. Barajlarda su kalmayacak.
Kuraklıktan dolayı üretim düşecek.
Bunlar rahatlıkla yorumlanabilecek
cümleler. E kurak olursa orman yangının
çıkma ihtimali daha yüksek olur. Şimdi
Türkiye'de afetlere gelmeden önce
Allah'tan aklıma geldi. Tekrar şu
tabloya tekrar bir geri dönelim. Tamam
mı? Şimdi bak. Sel ve taşkın. E bu hocam
havadan gelen iklimle alakalı bir şey. O
yüzden meteorolojik, klimatolojik bir
şey. Kuraklık e havayile alakalı. Çığ,
kar yağacak, fırtına, kasırga, hortum
havayla alakalı. O zaman biz bunlara
meteorolojik, klimatolojik afet dedik.
Tamam. Bu tarafa geldim. Bunları da
şöyle kabaca görelim gençler. Beşeri
faaliyetler sonucunda ortaya çıkan
afetlere bak. Sosyal afetler. Bak bunlar
sosyal savaş. Yangın. Yangından kastı
orman yangını değil. Bak orman yangını
başka. Yangın, ev yangınları mesela.
Sosyal bir şey. Göçler sosyal bir
afettir. Hocam göç afet afet midir? E
Suriye'den yaşanılan bu göçler sizce bir
afet değil mi? Milyonlarca insan göç
ediyor burada. Terör saldırıları birer
afettir. Afete neden olur? Unutmayın.
Bakın bunlar sosyaldi. Bir de bak
teknolojik afetler var. insan yapıyor.
Sosyali de teknolojiyi de insan yapıyor.
Ulaşım kazası teknoloji sonucunda
oluşur. Maden kazaları. Soma'da
yaşadığımız maden kazası teknolojik
beşeri bir afet. Sanayide yaşanan
kazalar, nükleer kazalar, kimyasal
silahlar hepsi bakın insan faaliyeti
sonucunda. Nükleer denildiğinde insana
koyarsın bunu. Bu basit. Şimdi gelelim
Türkiye'de afetler kısmına. Şimdi sen
biliyorsun afetleri öğrendin. Çığı
nedir, tsunami nedir? Bunun Türkiye'deki
kısımlarını göstereceğim sana. Şuraya
bak. Türkiye'de hayatını kaybeden insan
oranına göre afetler. Ülkemizde en fazla
hayatını insanların kaybetmesine neden
olan afet depremdir. Yani bunu hani
ezberlemene gerek yok. Kendi ülkemizi
bir düşün. İnsanlar binlerce insanımızı
kaybediyoruz bir depremde sadece. Demek
ki en fazla can kaybına neden olan afet
deprem. Neden bunu böyle ayrıntılı
söylüyorum? Çünkü en fazla yaşanan afet,
gerçekleşen afet deprem değil. En fazla
gerçekleşen afet kütle hareketleri.
Bakın depremler %6, kütle hareketleri
%28. Türkiye'de demek ki en fazla
gerçekleşen afet kütle hareketleri.
Kütle hareketleri neydi? Kaya düşmesi,
heyel, çamur akıntılarıydı, değil mi?
Bakın en fazla bunlar yaşanıyormuş. Ama
bunlar o kadar can ve mal kaybına neden
olmuyor. Bakın kütle hareketlerinin eee
neden olduğu can kaybı %0.1. Çok düşük
bak. Ama en fazla hangisi yaşanıyor?
Kütle hareketleri. En fazla can kaybı
depremde. Bakın Türkiye'de afetlerin en
çok olduğu il Erzurum, Trabzon, Bingöl,
Rize. Neden? Erzurum'u az sonra
göreceğiz. Sel ve Taşkın Erzurum'da.
Çağı Erzurum'da. Heylan Erzurum'da.
Birçok afetin merkezi. Bakın şimdi
geçelim oraya. Şimdi Türkiye'de deprem.
Bizim ülkemiz neydi gençler? Alp
Himalaya deprem kuşağındaydı değil mi?
Şuranın altını çizelim. Türkiye Alp
Himalaya deprem fay hattı kuşağında.
Hani Alpler ve Himalayalara geçen
aradayız biz. Ve bunun sonucunda bakın
şurada Kuzey Anadolu fay hattımız var.
Bunu çizmeyi öğrenin. Şurası bakın Kuzey
Anadolu fay hattı. Doğu Anadolu fay
hattı ve Batı Anadolu fay hattı. Şimdi
şöyle bir soru sorulabiliyor.
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi Kuzey Anadolu
fay hattında değildir? Bakın Elazığan
direkt sınav sorusunu veriyorum size.
Elazığ Kuzey Anadolu fay hattında mı?
Hayır. Bu soruyu çözebilmen için illerin
yerini bilmen lazım. Kuzey Anadolu fay
hattının nereden geçtiğini bilirsin sen
zaten. Kuzey Anadolu diyor. Kuzeyden.
Batı Anadolu fay hattı bak batıdan. Doğu
Anadolu fayatı bak doğuya doğru gidiyor.
Elazığ doğuda ama Erzincan bak sorulursa
bunlar karıştırıldığı için böyle
sorulur. Elazığ Doğu Anadolu'da ama
Erzincan kuzeyde. Bakın Bolu zaten
kuzeyde. Bunu bilirsin. Amasya zaten
kuzeyde. Bunu bilirsin ama şurada Elazığ
doğuda bunu unutma ya. Batıdan iller
söylesi Aydın, Muğla, Balıkesir dese
size bunu zaten çıkartırsın lütfen.
Burada Erzincan kuzeyde, Elazığ doğuda.
Bu illerin yerini bilmen lazım. O yüzden
sana her seferinde uygulamayı,
coğrafyanın kodları uygulamasını indir.
Orada oyunla beraber oyna bunu dememin
nedeni de bu. Böyle bir soru sorulabilir
bize. Tamam. Bu deprem, ülkemizde en çok
tektonik deprem görülüyordu. Volkanik
deprem. E volkan yok nasıl görünsün?
Çöküntü depremleri kalkerili arazide
işte şurada Toroslarda görülebilir.
Tektonik deprem asıl bizim deprem
dediğimiz depremdi. Yerin altından gelen
güçtü. O yüzden tektonik depremler
ülkemizde en fazla görülür. Bizim
ülkemiz nasıldı? Genç oluşumluydu. Genç
oluşumlu Alp Himalaya deprem kuşağında
olduğumuz için ülkemiz bir deprem
bölgesiydi. Karstik arazi, az önce
söyledim bunu. Karstik arazinin olduğu
yerde de çöküntü depremine
rastlayabiliriz diye. Ülkemizde tsunami.
Bunu tsunami konusunu anlatırken
gösterdim sana. Tsunami olma ihtimali
yüksektir ülkemizde. Çünkü deprem
geçiyor ve bu deprem denizlerin yanında
geçiyor. Denizimiz de var. En riskli
bölge gençler Ege ve Marmara'dır. Sonra
Akdeniz Karadeniz'de çok nadir
görülmüştür. Türkiye'de volkanizma.
Donmuşum. Niye söylemiyorsunuz ya
gençler? Ülkemizde aktif volkan yok.
Aktiften kastımız aslında literatürde
işte 10.000 yılda bir patladıysa
aktiftir gibi bazı kavramlar var. Yani
akademik olarak bakınca aktif volkan
aslında olmuş oluyor ülkemizde ama ya
aktiften kastımız bizim genelde şu an
patlayan bir şey görüyor muyuz? En son
patlama 1441'de yaşanmış. Nerede?
Tendürek'te. Unutma bak. Tendürek'te en
son patlama. Nemrut Süpan, Tendürek ağrı
vardı ya hani orada genelde sönmüş
olduğu kabul ediliyor ülkemizde. Ama şu
son zamanlarda eee bazı haberler var.
Kula volkanlarının çevresinde bilim
adamları buralarda hareketlilik
hissediyormuş. Araştırma yapıyorlar
orada. Tamam. Yani tekrardan bir
harekete geçme olayı yaşanabilir.
Ülkemizdeki kütle hareketleri. Kütleden
kastımız neydi? Kaya düşmesi. Özellikle
de heylan, çamur akıntısı ama heylan.
Gençler bakın heylanın nerede
yaşandığını bilmeniz lazım. Bunu bilmek
de çok basit aslında. Hey lan gelme.
Dağın kopup gelmesi. Dağ kopup gelmesi
için eğim lazımdı. Dağın kopup gelmesi
için suya doyması lazımdı. E bunlar
nerede? Karadeniz'de. Bakın Giresun,
Trabzon Rizi, Artvin. Bu bölgeyi
işaretliyorsunuz. Bir de Kastamonu
özellikle de Kastamonu. Kastamonu ve
hafif çevresini işaretliyorsunuz. Bakın
Karadeniz'de en fazla dikkat etmeni
istediğim bir kısım var burada. Bakın
Erzurum. Erzurum da bunun içerisinde.
Erzurum'u da alıyorsunuz. Neden? Kar
erimelerinden dolayı. Demek ki heyın
olduğu bölgeler bu haritayı sana
verdiğinde işin içinde Kastamonu varsa,
işin içinde böyle Erzurum'u da işin
içerisine aldığında kütle hareketleri,
özellikle de heylan haritası
diyebilirsin buna. Tamam. Ne lazım bize?
Su, yağmur, eğimli arazi lazım. E bu da
Karadeniz'de var. Heylanı öğrendik az
önce. E erozyonu nerede rastlayacağız
hocam? E neresi kurkizde? Bunu
ezberlemene gerek yok ki. Türkiye'ye
gel. Şuraya bak. Erozyon. Şöyle. Neresi
kurak? Türkiye'nin %86'sı kurak. Birçok
yer kuraktır gençler. Ülkemiz kurak yarı
kurak bölge. Özellikle bak şu şuraları
görüyor musun? Özellikle iç ve Güneydoğu
Anadolu kısım kuraklığın çok şiddetli
olduğu bölge. Erozyon şu bakın her taraf
kurak. Karadenizde bir belki birazcık
erozyon. Onun dışında her taraf kurak
yarı kurak. Ülkemizin %86'sı erozyon
tehlikesiyle karşı karşıyadır. Bunu
unutma. Niye? Çünkü ülkemizde eğimli
arazi fazla. E bu eğimli araziler de
bitki örtüsüle tahrip edilmiş durumda.
Toprağın üstü yontulup gidiyor. E
ülkemiz kurak yarı kurak bir bölge.
Yanlış tarım arazileri yapıyoruz. tarım
uygulaması yapıyoruz. Ne yapıyoruz?
Eğime yatay paralel sürüyoruz. Böyle
olunca toprak kayıp gidiyor. Ya da anız
yakıyoruz. Toprağın üstündeki anızı
yakınca toprak çıplak kalıyor. Erozyona
neden oluyor. Yağışlarımız da düzensiz.
Yağışlar yağmıyor, yağmıyor. Bir anda
yağıyor. Alıyor toprağın üstünü
götürüyor. Bu da etkili. Türkiye'de
rüzgarlar çok öyle şiddetli rüzgarlar
yaşamıyoruz biz gençler. Özellikle böyle
tropikal rüzgarlar falan bizim ülkemizde
yok. Böyle küçük çaplı hortumlar yaşansa
da küresel iklim değişiminden dolayı
Akdeniz kısmında özellikle böyle
tropikal rüzgarlar, fırtınalar,
kasırgalar böyle bir durum değil. Sel ve
taşkınlar. Burada bilmen gereken
Türkiye'de sel ve taşkının ne olduğunu
az önce öğrendik. Türkiye'de bakın
Nisan, Mayıs Haziran aylarında daha çok
görülüyor. Burası önemli. Buraya yıldız
at altını çiz. Neden? Çünkü gençler bu
dönem bizim karların erime dönemleri. Ve
dikkat edin yine Erzurum çıktı
karşımıza. Kar erelerinden dolayı ciddi
anlamda buralarda sel ve taşkınlar
yaşanabiliyor. Bakın Sivas kar
erimeleri, Adana kısmı. E bu bölge Seyan
Ceyhan nehrinin bulunduğu bölge. Bakın
Van Bitlis kısmı. Buralar dağlık
çığların yaşandığı kara erimelerin
yaşandığı bölgeler. Demek ki özellikle
Erzurum'un, Sivas'ın, Van'ın, Şu hattın
olduğu yerde Sel ve taşkını ekleyeceğiz.
Tamam. Türkiye'nin genelinde bakın yine
birçok yerde olabiliyor. Büyük
şehirlerden dolayı şehirlerde de
yaşanabiliyor. Niye Samsun'da var
mesela? Bak Samsun'da dikkat et.
Kızılırmak, Yeşil Irmak nehirlerinin
geldiği ve denize ulaştığı yer Adana.
Yine aynı şekilde Erzurum burada tepeyi
çekiyor. Bak Türkiye'de çığ. Geçen sene
sırayla bunun üzerinde durmuştum. Çığı
ile alakalı sorular gelmiyor diye. Buna
dikkat edelim diye çığı soruldu.
Türkiye'de orman yangınına kayabilirler
ama çığdan da yine devam da edebilirler.
Çünkü çığ kısmını genel sorular
içerisine koymuşlardı. Direkt çığı değil
de çığın işaretli olduğu yer
sormuşlardı. Belki bu sene direkt çığı
da sorabilirler. O yüzden şu çığa dikkat
et. Bir kodlama yapmıştım size. Ç harfi.
Çı. Bak Ç harfi koymuştuk şuraya.
Görüyor musunuz? Çığ denildiğinde bize Ç
harfi. E buralar dağlık bölge. Kar
yağışının fazla olduğu bölge. Bak nerede
görülüyor çığ? Bak Türkiye'nin diğer
ucundan diğer ucuna getirdim Hakkari'ye.
Ve Ç harfi koydum. Çığın görüldüğü en
çok yer. Bakın Bingöl, Bitlis. Özellikle
başta onlar var ama çığ denildiğinde
burası geliyor aklımıza. Bakın yine
Kastamonunda da hafif almış. Bu haritayı
sen niye karıştırmayacaksın heylanla?
Çünkü en fazla görüldüğü yer Bittlis.
Bingöl. Bu da çığ haritamız. Bingöl.
Bitlis, Tunceli, Hakkari dağlık
bölgeler. Bölge olarak da Doğu Anadolu
Türkiye'de orman yangınları dikkat edin.
E nerede olacak orman yangını hocam?
Akdeniz iklimin görüldüğü bu hatta
olacak daha çok. Bakın ülkemizin %60'ı
risk altındaymış. Evet bizim ülkemizdeki
teknolojik afetler gençler şunun altını
çiz burada şöyle %99'u karayolunda.
Bizde en çok ulaşım ulaşım kazaları bize
nükleer yeni geliyor. Nükleer kaza yok
bizde mesela ulaşım kazaları var bizde.
Evet çoğu ulaşım kazaları. Şimdi
geliyoruz afetlerden korunma yollarına.
Afetlerden korunma aslında bu dersin en
önemli kısmı burası. Bana göre öyle ama
sorularda öyle çok fazla sormuyorlar.
Çünkü biz bu dersi genel olarak hani
sınav odaklığı öğrenmediğimizde neden
öğrenmemiz gerekiyor? Afetlerden
korunmak için. Şöyle bakın. Özellikle
deprem, volkanizma, tsunami, kasırga.
Bunları böyle önlemek pek mümkün değil.
Mesela depremi önleyebilir misiniz?
Önleyemezsiniz. Ama bunları önlem
alsanız can ve mal kayıplarını
azaltabilirsiniz. O yüzden afetlerden
korunma önemlidir. Afet öncesinde
yapılması gerekenler diye şöyle bir
bütüncül afet yönetimi diye bir kısmımız
var. Şu bütüncül afet yönetimi şeması
şurası gençler. Afet öncesinde yapılması
gereken risk yönetimi aşamalarıdır. Yani
afetin öncesinde yapmamız lazım bunları.
Ve biz buna risk yönetimi diyoruz. Bak
afetten önce yani risk ve zararları
azaltma, hazır olma. Bunlar afetten önce
yapılmalı. Yani önlem alacağız. Tahmin
ve erken uyarı sistemleri koyacağız.
Bunlar da afetten sonra yapılması
gerekenler. Şu ikinci kısımda. Bunlara
da biz kriz yönetimi diyoruz. Şöyle
şöyle kriz yönetimi. Şöyle tabloyu bir
daha bak. Sen de benim çizdiğim gibi
çizebilirsin kafanda tam netleşmesi
için. Şurası afetten önce yapılması
gerekiyor. Risk yönetimini oluşturuyor.
Burası da kriz yönetimini oluşturuyor.
Afetten sonra yapılıyor. Şimdi bak sen
müdahaleyi afet yaşandıktan sonra
yaparsın değil mi? Afet anında yani ve
iyileştirmeyi afetten sonra yaparsın.
Bunlar da afet kriz yönetiminde mesela
bunları böyle afet afet değerlendirirsek
ki sorulursa bize soru buradan çıkacak
işte depremden önce, deprem sırasında ve
deprem sonrasında yapılacaklar diye.
Bunları tabii ezberlemene gerek yok.
Birazcık yorumlaman lazım. Ben
yorumlayamayacağın kısım varsa şimdi
bunları göstereceğim sana. Mesela halkı
eğitimiği deprem sırasında yapabilir
misin ya da deprem sonrasında? Hayır.
Depremden önce yapman gerekir. Halk
eğitilmesini. Deprem olduğu zaman neler
yapılır, neler yapmalıyız diye konuşmayı
depremden önce yapman lazım. Bunu
yorumlarsın. Eşyalarını sabitlemeyi evde
depremden önce yapman lazım. Deprem
çantasını depremden önce hazırlamalısın.
Depremden önce nasıl bir pozisyon alman
gerektiğini depremden önce öğrenmelisin.
Peki deprem sırasında deprem olurken ne
yapmalıyım gençler? Birincisi panik
yapmayacaksınız. Panik yaparsanız doğru
kararlar alamazsınız deprem sırasında.
Bir de böyle merdivenlere
atlamayacaksınız. Deprem yaşanırken
uygun yerlere yani hayat üçgeni
oluşturacak yerlere uygun pozisyon siper
alacaksın. başını koruyup özellikle
hayat üçgeni dediğimiz sana koruma
sağlayacak bölgelere geçeceksin. Böyle
sağlam bir şey bulur. Mesela benim şu
masa sağlam değil. Bu masanın altına
geçmemeliyim ama yatağım çok sağlam.
Benim yatağın yanına böyle geçersem
üzerime bir şey düştüğünde büyük bir
ihtimalle yataktan dolayı yatak şöyle ya
şöyle üstüne bir şey düştüğünde şöyle
bir hayat üçgeni oluşturacak. Bak arada
gördün mü? Yatak çünkü böyle üzerine
böyle yıkıldığında şu arada bakın hayat
üçgeni oluşturacak bana. Benim gidip
hemen yatağın kenarına kafamı koruyacak
şekilde çömelmem gerekiyor. Tabii benim
yatağım sağlam. İçi de dolu bu arada boş
değil. O yüzden burası benim beni
koruyabilecek bir yer. Bir de ben üst
kattayım. Bu benim için çok sağlıklı.
Ben bunun önlemini önceden mesela ne
yapabilirim diye düşündüm. Öncesinde
yapılması gerekenler. Deprem sırasında
işte ne yapacağım? Hemen hayat üçgeni
olan yere gideceğim. Asansör
kullanamazsın. Deprem sırasında
devrilecek bir eşya varsa hemen ondan
uzak duracaksın. Eğer trafikteysen
arabayı durduracaksın ve bekleyeceksin.
Tamam. Bunlar deprem sırasında yapılması
gerekenler. Deprem oldu. Geldim hemen
yatağımın kenarına kafamı koruyacak
şekilde. Kafa çok önemli burada.
Kafamızı koruyacak şekilde hayat üçgeni
alanı bulduk. Çömdük ve deprem geçti.
Hemen ne yapacağız? Hemen gideceğiz gaz,
su vanalarını, elektrik aletlerini
kapatacağız ve binayı terk edeceğiz. Ama
bak şunu unutuyoruz. Gaz, suvanaları,
elektrikli aletler, şartelleri indir
mesela. Gazı kapat, suvar vanalarını
kapat, evden çık. Ve evden çıktığında
toplanma alanları oluyor. Daha böyle
açık alanlar bunlar. Çünkü bir bina bir
daha yaşanabilir ve senin bina üstüne
devrilebilir. Binadan bir şeyler
düşebilir üstüne. Enkazlar varsa enkaz
arasında dolaşma. Açık bir alana
gideceksin. Tamam. Bak dikkat et. Öncesi
sana soru sorulduğunda soruyu düzgün
oku. Öncesinde, sırasında, sonrasında
diye sorulacaktır. Soruyu düzgün
okuyarak cevap ver. Tamam mı? Bu
depremden korunma yollarıydı. Peki hocam
tsunamiden korunma yolları neler?
Tsunami gençler önceden bilinebiliyor.
Biz şimdi depremi çok önceden
bilebiliyor muyuz? Hayır, bazı
uygulamalar var Android'de. Ben mesela
Apple kullandığım için ben onu bir türlü
kullanamadım ama Android'de böyle 10
saniye önce, 30 saniye önce galiba böyle
bir bilgi veren bir durum var. Artık ne
kadar işlevsel olur 10 saniye önce
verilen o bilgi yine yani tetikteyseniz
ve bunu bir kere yaşadıysanız telefon
geldiği gibi birç yoktan 1015 saniyeniz
olabilir. Böyle bir durum var. Tsunamiyi
önceden bilebiliyoruz. Neden biliyor
musunuz? Az önce size şey yapmıştım ya,
göstermiştim ya tsunaminin yaşanacağı
bölgeleri. Mesela şurada yaşanan bir
deprem. Deprem sonrasında ta buraya
kadar dalga gidebiliyor ve buradaki
yerlere haber iletilip tsunami
yaşanabilir diye önlem aldırtılabiliyor.
Bunu unutmayın tamam mı? Tsunamilerde
önlem alınabiliyor ya da tsamilerde
şöyle bir durum da oluyor. Tsamiler
yaşanacağı zaman sular bir çekiliyor
geri. Ne yapacaksın? Sen bunu bir
coğrafya dersi öğrendin. Bunu
bileceksin. Sular kıyıdan böyle bir geri
çekilme yaşadıysa sen uyanık olacaksın.
Sen coğrafya dersi görsün. Gördün. Sular
çekilmiş. Hiç görmediğin bir şey. Hiç
yaşamadığın bir şey. Ha diyeceksin.
Tsunami yaşanma ihtimali var. Hemen
kıyıdan çıkacaksın. Yüksek yerlere
gideceksin. Tamam. Peki heylandan
korunma yolları neler? Ne yapacaksın?
Heylanın olduğu yere, olma ihtimali olan
yere yerleşim yeri kurmayacaksın. Ya da
eğer bu heylan insan kaynaklı
yaşanıyorsa yol yapımında ne bileyim
oradan toprak alımı gibi yer şeyler de
olabiliyor. Araziden kazma kazım
yapılabiliyor. Böyle şeyler yapmamaya
çalışacaksın. Çünkü bunlar tetikliyor
heylanı. Şimdi heylanı önlemeye yönelik
tabii ki tamamen engellenemez heylan ama
biraz olsun e önleme çalışması olarak
hiçbir şey yapamaz mıyız hocam? Bakın
yamaca beton duvarlar yapılabilir ama ne
kadar etkili olabilir yani ya da ana
kayaya inecek derinlikte kazıklar
çakmak. Bu çok zor bir şey bu arada.
Çelikleri çakacaksınız ana kayaya inene
kadar derine. Çok zor bir iş. Eğimli
yamaçlarda taraçalar yapmak. Ya şimdi
bunlar heylanı böyle tamamen engellemez
gençler. Böyle engelleyemezsiniz bunu.
Ya önlem alırsınız. Belki etkisini daha
sonraki bir zamana aktarırabilirsiniz.
Yani hiçbir şey yapmamaktan iyidir. Soru
sorulduğunda buna dikkat edin. Şurada
erozyonu önge engellemek için bak dikkat
edin. Ağaç dikmek demedi. Yani ağaç
dikerseniz heyelanı engelleyebilir
misiniz? Yani ben heyelan bölgesinde
yaşıyorum. Buraya ağaç dikeyim. Heylan
olmasın. Hani bu çok zor bir iş. Belki
ağacın kökleri toprağa tutabilir. Bu da
tamamen bitirmez ama belki yani belki
önlem alıyormuş gibi olursun. Belki
etkisini azaltırsın. daha geç zamanda
olabilecaktır. Ama bu ağaç siktiğinde
kayacaksa kayar orası. Tamam. Ama bakın
erozyonu engellemek. Erozyon toprağın
yontulması. Toprağın yontulması. Bakın
burası nasıl kurak yarı kurak bir resmi
yer. Sen buraya böyle ağaçlar
diktiğinde, bitkiler diktiğinde toprağın
yontulmasını engellersin. Unutma sen
burayı ağaçlandırırsan eroz yontulamaz.
Artık toprak yontulamaz. Sen buralara
böyle taraça taraça basamaklar yaparsan
toprağın yontulması zorlaşır. Toprak
yontulamaz. Demek ki taraça yapmak
toprağı erozyu engelleyebilir. Arazileri
eğime dik sürmek. Bak eğime paralel
sürersen kayar gider. Eğime dik sürersen
bak bu güzel bir şey. Erozyontu
azaltabilirsin erozyonun etkisini.
Meraları aşırı otlatmazsan erozyonu
engelleyebilirsin. Topraktaki bitkiyi,
çayır çimeni aşırı otlatmazsan ne olur?
Çayırlar geri kalır. O zaman toprak
yontulamaz. Bak bu kadar. Bunu
soruyorlar. Bunları yorumlamayı öğren.
Bak aynı aynı bu cümleleri sordular.
Tarlaları Nadas'a bırakmamak lazım.
Neden? Bak Nadas ne demek? Bak tekrar
tekrar anlatıyorum. Bu adamlar da her
sene gelip aynı şeyi soruyorlar. Artık
bıktı bak. Nadas susuz tarımı toprağı
bir sene ektin sen. Tamam. Sonra sonraki
sene toprakta su olmadığı için kurak
yarı kurak bölgede ya ben bir seni
bırakayım bu toprağı çıplak bırakayım.
Ben buraya tarım ürünü ekmeyeyim
diyorsun. Ekmeyince toprak su tutsun
diyorsun. Şimdi şimdi bir sene ektin.
Toprakta bitkiler oldu. Tarım ürünü
oldu. Ne oldu? Toprağın üstü kapalı.
Eroz yontulamaz. Ama sen bir sene boş
bıraktığında Nadasa'a bıraktığında Nadas
susuz tarım Nadas'a bıraktığında
toprağın üstü çıplak kaldı bir sene
boyunca. Ya toprağın üstündeki
mineraller süpürüldü gitti. Bak erozyona
neden oldu. Demek ki Nadas toprağı
Nadas'a bırakmak erozyona neden
oluyormuş. Bak burada Nadas'a bırakmak
demiyor. Nadasa'a bırakmamak diyor. Ha
demek ki toprağın üstünü Nadasa'a
bırakmamak lazım. Tamam. Bir diğeri
nöbetleşe ekim yapmak lazım. Bak, Nadas
kötü bir şey. Erozyon için. Nadas'a
bırakırsan erozyon olur. Nöbetleşi
ekimse güzel bir şey. Neden? Çünkü bir
sene toprağı ekmişsin sen. Pamuk
ekmişsin. Tamam. Sonraki sene bunu
nadasa bırakacağına, boş bırakacağına ya
niye boş bırakıyorum diyorsun. Buraya
başka bir şey ekeyim. Su istemeyen bir
ürün ekeyim. Mercimek ekeyim diyorsun.
Su o kadar istemiyor bildiğim kadarıyla.
Bu sefer boş bırakacağına ne yaptın?
Nöbetleştin. Bir onu bir de bu nöbeti
ektin. Bir de onu. Ha bak toprağı boş
bırakmadın. Toprakta tarım ürünü oldu.
Böylece toprak boş kalmayınca erozyont
olmadı. Demek ki nöbetleşe hekim güzel
bir şey. Nadas kötü bir şey. Anlaştık
mı? Orman alanlarını korursan erozyon
olamaz. Orman var nasıl yontulsun
toprak? İnsanları bilinçlendirirsen
insanlar ormanları korur. İnsanlar
nöbetleşik kim yapar? İnsanlar nadasa
bırakmaz. Erozyon engellenmiş olur.
Eğimli arazileri tarım alanı yapmamak
lazım. Sen şimdi normalde eğrimli
arazide çayır var, orman var. Sen burayı
tarım alanı yaparsan sonuçta bu tarım
alanını bir süre sonra ne oluyor? Bir
dönem çıplak kalması lazım. Tarım ürünü
olmadığı dönem yani ekilmeyen dönem.
Tarım alanına çevirirsen sen burayı eroz
yonta zemin hazırlıyorsun. E yamaçlarda
tel çitler yapmak. Toprak yontulmasın
diye çitler yaparsan erozytu
engellersin. Meraları ıslah edersen
iyileştirmektir ıslah etmek. Allah seni
ıslah etsin. Böyle düşün.
iyileştirirsen, meraları, çayırları
iyileştirirsen daha çok çayır olur. O
zaman erozyont engellenmiş olur.
Yontulamaz toprak. Bak hep yontulamaz
dersen çıkıyor yorum. Böyle
yorumlayacaksın. Tamam. Peki sel ve
taşkınlardan nasıl korunacağız? Selin
nasıl oluştuğunu öğrenmiştik. İnsanlar
yerleşim yerlerine, vadilere yerleşim
yapıyordu. Su yataklarına, dere
yataklarına yerleşim yaptığı için sev ve
taşkınlar yaşanıyordu. İşte akarsu
yatağı daralınca sev ve taşkınlar
artıyordu. Bir kere burada erken uyarı
sistemi oluşturulabilir. Mantıken
düşünsene. Yağmur yağacak. Ne kadar
yağmur yağacak? Metrekareye ne kadar su
düşecek? Bunlar aslında hesaplanabilir
ya da yağmur başladığında bununla
alakalı ölçümler yapılabilir. Bu da
erken uyarı sistemiyle beraber insanlara
uyarılabilir. Dere yataklarına yerleşim
yeri kurmayacağız dedik. Derenin
önlerini tıkamayacağız. Su akıp
gidebilecek yoksa taşkın olur.
Ağaçlandırmayı arttıracağız. Bu
bölgedeki bitkileri koruyacağız. Bu
arada bazı bölgelerde gençler kanallar
oluşturulabiliyor. Kanallar
oluşturacağız. Su çok aktığı dönemlerde
akarsuyun yanında bazen böyle kol gibi
bir kanal oluşturulabiliyor. E çok fazla
akıyorsa, sel yaşanacaksa o kanalı
açarsınız. Suyun bir kısmı da o
kanallara doğru gider. Böylece o kanalla
gölete gider mesela. Böylece set
taşkının önüne geçebilirsiniz. Çığ
yaşandığında şunu unutmayın. Çığın
merkez kısmında daha çok kar olur.
Kıyılarına kaçmaya çalışacağız çığ
yaşandığında. Gençler bakın oturma
pozisyonu almamız gerekiyormuş. Çığ
yaşandığında herhalde şöyle. Bu konuda
benim bilgim yok. Yani şöyle oturma
pozisyonu almamız gerekiyormuş. Hangi
mantıkla bilmiyorum ama öyleymiş. Eğer
araçtaysa motor durdurulmalı oksijenden
dolayı. Kontrollü bir şekilde yapağı çığ
gerçekleştirilmeli. Tabii bunu biz
gerçekleştirmeyeceğiz. Bu bölgeler
gerekli kuruluşlarca takip edilmesi
gerekiyor. Çığın yaşanacağını
anladıkları bölgelerde ses yapıyorlar.
Ses bombası falan atıyorlar. Belki
belgesellerde izlemişsinizdir. Yapay bir
çığ oluşturuyorlar. Ulaşım yolları çığ
bölgesinden geçmemeli. Spor yapılan
yerler belirlenirken dikkat edilmeli.
Çığ oluşacaksa oluşma ihtimali olan
yerlere o kayak e pistleri yapılmamalı.
Evet. Kuraklık. Kuraklıkta en önemli şey
bizim yapabileceğimiz yani korunma
yollarını görüyoruz. Şu an bizim
yapabileceğimiz şey tarım alanları
sulanırken gençler damlama sulama
yöntemi uygulanmalı. Bunun altını
çizmenizi istiyorum. Çünkü burada
karışıklık olabiliyor. Şöyle damlama
sulama yapılmalı. Damlama sulamayı
görmüşsünüzdür. Hortumda delik oluyor.
Damla damla suluyor. Bir de sallama
sulama var. Dilim iyice dönmüyor yaradan
dolayı. İnşallah çok fark
ettirmemişimdir sizle ders anlatırken.
Bayağı uzadığı için video artık
zorlanıyorum. Salma sulama. Bak suyu
salıyorsunuz. Bu çok kötü bir şey
gençler. Düşünsenize tarlaya sulu
salıyorlar. Görmüşsünüzdür. E ne oluyor?
Suyun çoğu buharlaşıp gidiyor. O salma
sulamada o kadar suyu salarsan
düşünsenize yani dere gibi su
salıyorsunuz. Bütün mineralleri yıkayıp
götürüyor toprağın altına. Çok kötü bir
şey salma sulama. Bunu anneniz babanız
yapıyorsa yaptırmayın. Toprağınız yok
olur gider. Ne yapılması lazım? Damlama
sulama. Damlama sulama nasıl? Damla
damla. Orada hep o nemin durmasını
sağlıyor. Bitki istediği zaman
alabiliyor. Mineral yıkanıp aşağıya
gitmiyor. Değil mi? Buna çok dikkat
edin. İçme kullanma suyunu tasarruflu
kullanacağız ki kuraklık yaşamayalım.
Evet. Kasırga ve fırtınadan korunma
yolları. Bu konuda bizim ülkemizde hani
çok fazla kasırga fırtına yaşamasak da
Amerika'da görmüşsünüzdür dizilerde,
belgesellerde neleri var Amerikalıların?
Sığınakları var değil mi? Bakın şurada
sığınakları olduğu için o sığınaklara
giriyorlar. Kasırga ve fırtınalara zaten
çok önceden haber alabiliyorlar. Önlem
de o yüzden alınabiliyor. Çok önceden
gençler duyuruluyor kasırga geliyor
diye. İnsanlar da sığınaklara
giriyorlar. Sularını, yemeklerini oraya
depoluyorlar. Sığınaklara giriyorlar.
Evet. Yıldırım konusunda dikkat edin
gençler. Zaten paratonerler evlere
koyuluyor ama bir gün böyle yağmurlu çok
şey bir durumda kalırsak yıldırımların
düşebileceği bir yerde o zaman ne
yapacaksınız? Arazideki gençler tek ağaç
direk veya benzeri şeylerden uzak
duracağız. Tamam. Bunu unutmayın. Çünkü
büyük bir ihtimalle o yıldırımı
çekebilir. Yani bir tane işte arazide
çok yağmur yağıyor. Gidip bir ağacın
altına, arazide tek bir tane ağaç var.
Onun altına girmeyin. Yıldırım düşebilir
oraya. Eğer yüksek yerdeyseniz çukur
yere geçeceksiniz. Tamam mı? Yani oranın
en yüksek kısmı siz olmayacaksınız.
Oraya düşecek çünkü Yıldırım. Sudan uzak
duracaksınız. Çarparsa sizde çarpacak
çünkü suyla beraber. Elinizle metal
şeyler taşımayacaksınız. Metale geliyor
ya. Bak araçta da camı kapatıp herhangi
bir metal kısmına değmemeye
çalışacaksınız aracın. Tamam mı? Orman
yangını. E mangalımızı söndürmeden
bırakmayacağız. Mangal yakmayacağız.
Yani mangal gitmeyeceğiz abi ya. Kurak
dönemde böyle gidip sen Antalya'da
kızılçam ormanlarının içinde ne işin var
mangalda? İzmitini atmayacaksın sağa
sola. Baban atıyorsa annen uyaracaksın.
Cam parçalarını atmayacaksın. Mercek
görevi görüyor zaten. İtfaiye ve iş
makineleriyle işbirliği yapmak bizim
toplumumuz gerçekten bu konuda çok
duyarlı. Gördüğünüz Akdeniz'de yaşanan
orman yangınlarında ne kadar yardımcı
oldu insanlar. Ekipler kurulmalı bu
dönemde. Erken uyarı sistemleri. Erken
uyarı sistemi mi olur hocam orman
yangınında? Evet. Belirli bir dereceye
ulaştığında, hava sıcaklığı çok ciddi
derecelere ulaştığında ormanların yanma
ihtimali çok daha artıyor. Böyle
dönemlerde devlet o bölgedeki halkı
uyarmalı. Dikkat edin, daha çok dikkat
edin, izmarit atmayın diye. Bakın hava
destekli eee böyle uçaklarımızın olması
lazım. Bizim ne yazık ki bu konuda bir
türlü ciddi önlemler almakta biraz
gecikiyoruz biz. Bizim ülkemiz orman
yangınlarının, orman yangını afetinin
yoğun yaşandığı ülke. O zaman sen burada
bir tane uçak değil 10 tane uçak
yapacaksın arkadaş. Bunun bir çözümü yok
yani. Yapacaksın 10 tane uçak alacaksın
o zaman. Evet. Evet. Bitirmiş olduk
afetler kısmını da. Evet. Donmuşum bu
arada son kısımda gençler. Evet afetleri
bitirmiş olduk. Şunu söyleyeyim size.
Bakın kaç bayağı uzun oldu bu video. Ben
de yoruldum. Bir de hastalık da var.
Dilimde yara. Ama öyle ya da böyle
bitirdik. Hepimize geçmiş olsun. Şimdi
bakın gençler, bu afetler önemliydi.
Lütfen bunun sorusunu çözün. Şimdi
gelecek soru videomuz. O soru videosunu
lütfen çözmeden bu afetler konusunu
bitirdim demeyin. Tamam mı? Kaç beş ayrı
test çözeceğiz orada. O bizim için çok
önemli. Seviliyorsunuz gençler. Çok
uzadı. Daha fazla konuşmayayım.
Kendinize güzel bakın. Bir sonraki
derste soru çözümünde görüşmek üzere.
Kömürden elmasa dönüşebilmeniz
dileğiyle.